thank you
Joe Biden said
she was 12 and I was 30 and then all of
the teachers start laughing and cheering
and clapping in what many people in in
what uh many people are saying is an
inappropriate remark okay it's Friday
night so we're gonna be chilling having
a good time but for Joe Biden to be
speaking point to someone and say she
was 12 and I was 30. does he is he not
self-aware does he does he understand
like hey hey hey wow you don't bite it
don't go there that's that's that's who
you are and
um I guess it is who he is and it's also
funny because it was a t it was a speech
for teachers and they all start clapping
and laughing so I'm just like aha yeah
okay what else is new well uh there's
that and what we what we know about Joe
Biden and then there's the Matt Gates
story this is huge we got a breakdown
this is a I think I would not be
surprised this was a conspiracy actually
no wait it is a conspiracy I think
that's proven Matt Gates was accused of
uh serious impropriety
and uh they apparently was under
investigation because they claimed that
I think you know a few years ago he was
hooking up with 17 year old or something
and so all of these leftists started
saying you know child trafficking
investigation or something even though
it was like a 17 year old but it was
fake news Matt Gates said it was not
true and there was a guy extorting Matt
Gates's Dad saying I can make that go
away that guy gets prostate he's getting
prosecuted gets five years and and now
the prosecutors are recommending no
charges for netgates because the
witnesses have no credibility in other
words it sounds like the story was fake
from the beginning Matt Gates's family
was being extorted and somebody was
leaking it to the Press because
tribalism chaos whatever you want to
call it talk about an insane story so
we'll get into all that my friends but
before we get started head over to
timcast.com become a member to support
our work directly check out the shows we
did this week over at the unset the
uncensored members only Tim cast IRL
shows just head over to timcast.com sign
up click that Tim cast iron you'll see
them all neatly stacked about we had a
good time earlier in the week we played
Mary bang indict because we we try to we
try to pull the violence out of it but
that was that was a lot of good fun and
that was definitely not for the kids so
that's on the website and we've got
other shows like Tales from the inverted
world and the new inverted World
conversational show live is in
production and might even be ready to go
within a couple of weeks it's going to
be a whole lot of fun thank you all for
your support as members because you make
it all possible don't forget to smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
be the notification a lot of people have
been telling us for a while now YouTube
is not notifying anybody of the show
going live and some people are like you
know maybe you're being Shadow banned
okay well here's what you can do you can
prove that their censorship won't work
take the URL and share it so you can be
the notification I've started tweeting
out the link to the show I didn't know
it used to do that we're going to start
pushing this because if they want to
start de-ranking us then all you guys
have to do to support us is share it and
it'll be 10 times more powerful than any
of their censorship attempts so again
smash that like button joining us today
to talk about all of this and more is
Nick palmisano you nailed it nailed it I
was worried for a second
I really appreciate you guys having me
on uh who are you that's a great
question
um I think that uh it was Socrates this
no okay
um yeah so uh you know uh just recently
I created a documentary called send me
that was about uh the fall of
Afghanistan the fall of Kabul
um and I was one of the the 12 guys in
our group middle-aged dudes that went
over to Afghanistan you know as it was
all falling apart to evacuate as many
people as possible
um prior to that I've made a couple of
Hollywood movies uh comedies uh dramas
and uh prior to that I started a company
called Ranger up which was the first
military Lifestyle brand
um cornered Tim Kennedy in the UFC and
and Strike Force for 12 years and before
all that I was an army officer so that's
the that's the abbreviated version of my
life so you have a lot of a lot of
stories about what went down when
Afghanistan fell a lot of stories yeah
it was already even before the show
we're talking a little bit about it it
was crazy that we're hearing so we'll
definitely get into all that stuff so
thanks for hanging out man we also have
the T-shirt vendor himself humble
t-shirt Fender that is the most humble
absolutely today I'm wearing a little
history lesson on my shirt that reminds
people of what the democide is it says
specifically the government is way
deadlier than any virus and this is a
great conversation starter especially
you know at Thanksgiving the Small Talk
At the Airport this is the great this is
the best way to to start these
conversations you could start them by
just simply going to the best
politicalshirts.com that's the website
hope to see you there thanks for having
me I want everyone to imagine sitting
down for Thanksgiving and like the
turkeys brought out everyone's smiling
and then Luke grabs the knife and he
goes so the government kills a lot of
people I was like oh here he goes again
do you know who really is the turkey
you know what they put in this parking
yeah I can don't get me going and and
these are the shirts that are okay here
they're shirts that are censored we
can't even show you so that's true I
want to point you guys if you didn't see
earlier today pop culture crisis on
YouTube I was on from three to six I'm
Ian cross and you can net if you want to
get through Nick I'm glad you're here
man I talk a lot about this Afghanistan
surrender is how I've been framing it
because
because that's what what happened
equipment and humans were surrendered by
by a hapless military command at least
that's from what I see so I'm happy
you're here because I want to talk to
you about it I appreciate it get what
you see yeah
yeah as I booked Nick I was like man
Ian's gonna love talking to this guy so
I'm really excited for tonight's
conversation thank you guys all for
tuning in thank you all for notifying
your friends about our show we deeply
appreciate that let's get going yeah
when when you when when Afghanistan
comes up in conversation it looks like
Ian is has personally been personally
been slapped by Joe Biden he's like
blowing and levitating he's just like
when you hear the stories of uh like Tim
Kennedy you've worked with Tim that was
explaining I think it might have been on
one of Rogan's podcasts like a couple
months ago or three months ago that when
the women were trying to get their
babies into the military into the
airport and they would have no choice
but to try and throw them over the wall
babies and then they'd get caught in
barbed wire because they didn't know
there's barbed wire on both sides that's
right oh man all right let's let's start
with something that's still kind of
depressing but at least a little funny
in some sense from the New York Post
quote she was 12 I was 30. Biden leaves
viewers stunned in teachers speech
correction New York Post the crowd
cheers for him he laughed loudly they
laughed loudly in the AHA it's very
funny when a guy makes a joke about
that's a that's a that's a very large
age Gap you've got there they say
President Biden shocked viewers on his
Friday speech teachers when he
recognized an audience member and told
the crowd she was 12 and I was 30.
abiding lit up social media with the
confounding and seemingly inappropriate
aside he did not say what he did when he
was 30 and the wind was a preteen you
got to say hi to me Biden said
mid-speech at the National Education
Association at course in DC we go we go
back a long way she was 12 and I was 30.
but anyway this woman helped me get an
awful lot done huh as a 12 year old
that's maybe later in life but what's it
why would he bring that up I don't know
what is she helping him get done who is
this woman anyway this is all a mystery
to me so there's there's two
possibilities here one he's absolutely
brain fried and can't even talk properly
two he's a very dirty perverted bad
person well that's a fact that we can't
even mention and there's there's a lot
of other activity that happened before
this whether it's the Ashley Biden diary
whether it's the bunch of creepy videos
that are being censored by big Tech
social media whether it's him kissing
his granddaughter on the mouth two times
whether it's him at least two times that
we know on record and him being a career
politician when you're in Washington DC
we know for a fact intelligence agencies
use
um sex and use underage children as a
form of extortion as a form of
manipulation so him being in Washington
DC this long and and so many other
things that happened beforehand
definitely raise some serious questions
from my perspective I just wanna I'm
pulling this up right here and hopefully
this image comes so when people are like
why do you think Joe Biden's a pedo well
it's like well here's him kissing his
granddaughter on the lips as well the
public crowd how much time do you have
yeah he's definitely kissing him too
that's how many videos she kissed me
yeah it's like hey man I don't know
what's going on that's my wife look at
this look at this look at the people
look at this lady behind she's loving it
like look how happy they all are it's
the weirdest thing isn't it yeah mouth
kisses is kind of a weird thing is am I
missing something look I don't know I
don't know what world y'all y'all are
from the world I'm from family members
kissing each other on the lips is like
not a thing it doesn't happen yeah I
remember it when I was a kid and my
grandma kissed her on the mouth once and
one time I felt like her wetness out of
the between the lips
because they were drinking whiskey yeah
but why is everybody like staring at Joe
Biden kissing his Grand it's not the
only time he's done it but they're all
very happy about it like they're
laughing he was also referred wasn't he
referred to as pedo Pete by somebody it
wasn't that something recently if you
remember that as well and you know the
behavior there is is is is very
eye-opening and again you could jump to
your own you know assertions and
conclusions but there's there's a trail
of behavior here that is where we saw
look at here's another one like what it
I don't get it is this like a like a
Delaware thing people in Delaware like
kiss their grand their grandchildren on
the lips oh man yeah that's oddly
specific yeah I think I think Joe Biden
abused Hunter it explains all of
Hunter's Behavior it was Hunter at least
allegedly they called him Peter Peter uh
I don't know where that came from if it
was like in his texts or something that
was like the phone backup that got
released right yeah I've only heard I
haven't like seen I don't even know how
I would verify it if I saw it if I would
even be real or not but it's a little
disturbing if that's real and all the
teachers are cheering for it right yeah
yeah I guess so but you'll see people
I'm sharing with this being reality he's
like today we're gonna go to the Savage
bar and they're like yeah
they're like yeah
yeah it's like what the it's like
going up the tone cue and that makes
everyone clap and cheer but it like it's
not even a logical
expression it's very I kind of feel like
if you had a stage with Biden on it and
then his supporters on stage with him
but like you could see it and then he
said something like next Noah Russian
battle calf care and they'll started
cheering I'd be laughing like this is a
great show this is hilarious these
people are so dumb
boy it's the world we live in I guess
that's our president meanwhile the
economy is imploding you got uh the
market tanked what is it uh the the Dow
Jones fell below what it I think when
Biden first started it was about 30 300
now it's down to 29 so the economy is
worse in this picture the the Dow is
down you can see the red and the arrow
oh yeah look at this even that's amazing
look at this clip right there as we're
showing Joe Biden talking about some 12
year old that he knew when he was 30.
it's you can see the Dow watch showing a
drop of nearly two percentage points so
yeah you know how you guys doing
all right I'm looking at the Dow
all time
um it's tough to it's tough to tell
because they'll print large amounts of
money that'll naturally inflate the Dow
just because there's more Capital
doesn't mean the economy is doing better
though well you know just to put on my
conspiracy hat if I could
um just for a little bit here let me
dust it off here uh if if you do look
look at a lot of the Biden policies they
have directly created this economic
Havoc that we're dealing with for the
benefit of the few ruling Elites and
this is why a lot of people make the
assertions and theorize that maybe there
is some dirt on Biden that's some very
powerful people have on him that they're
using to of course influence policy in
America policy in America that's not
working in the best interest of the
American people working in the best
interest of the select few who might
have dirt on him and they're using that
dirt in order to push these policies
wrecking the economy maybe maybe but I
think dirt's the wrong way to look at it
I think it's more like you can do what
you want if you do as you as you're told
you know what I mean yes and then there
could be an extortion operation I I
think that's a little bit more likely I
don't know you were
I think in general terms I think it's
less about stuff like that I just think
it's more that large businesses the
elite have really significant lobbying
power and donation power and you know
their businesses can donate and super
Pacs can donate you know if you think
about you know our GDP and our success
almost all of it comes from small
business because small business you guys
know this you're a small business you
hire people you know you're always
growing you're thinking about how do I
do more how do I get bigger large
business thinks about efficiency
offshoring saving money and so there's
nobody that represents the average
American the small business owner
there's nobody that is truly putting
money time lobbying efforts into that
and so you know you end up with people
that are that only care about you know
significant interests
I wonder what Biden does when he like I
think he sleeps most the time and then
they wake him up and give him pills or
you know maybe they're yeah maybe
injections they've got uh big businesses
very much about the stockholders and
forever it's been about stockholder
value stockholder now they're they're
adding on shareholder value uh share am
I is am I getting this right well that's
like the the Klaus Schwab thing is like
planetary stakeholders I think it's
stakeholders now they're going from
shareholders which are the stock owners
to uh stakeholders as well which is who
has stake in this company doing well
which honestly is up for It's Up For
Debate like
if it's a company that wants to clean
the water in Portugal then all of the
Portuguese citizens become a stakeholder
in that company doing well and then they
can I don't know enough about it to
start going off and I've actually been
starting to read class Schwab's recent
book um and I'll definitely let you know
more but it's you know it's a way to
manipulate to get corporations like ESG
is like are you doing well for your
stakeholders as well as your
shareholders are you making the world a
better place for your stakeholders the
ESG stuff is the Communist Party of
America the the so you have the
Communist Party of China and what they
do is they get an office in all of these
companies you open a company you got to
have they got they gotta have an office
there and they control if you're in line
with the message and at some point some
U.S interests were like man that's a
good idea we could totally control
everything if we just forced this so you
had this uh this guy um Vivek uh Rama
Swami there you go there we go yeah he
was ragging on Disney because he was
like you're doing things that are
hurting the company for for ESG stuff
like stop doing that and then he even
called that State Street Vanguard and
was it BlackRock I think yeah he was
like just because they're big
shareholders doesn't mean you do what
they say they represent people and the
people don't want any of this stuff but
here's here's the thing man these those
three like that they own basically
everything they've got huge percentages
of basically everything super woke ESG
they're trying to control it's it's you
know what it is it's kind of like
I don't know if who is the right word
because not like they're storming the
gates and taking over but they're
they're definitely slowly taking over
everything and they're doing it through
the private sector and and the public
sector to be honest but they're they're
going to the private sector through ESG
as basically the Communist Party of
China does and they're they're getting
their offices they're getting their
influence and then if you don't do as
you're told you get banned you get you
get the ax you get shut out of society
we can't let them gain more control
simply put gotta fight back
how do you do that start small
businesses
start your own business make your own TV
shows incorporate mock Disney as they
collapse yeah so he's telling Disney
he's like you've got to stop this and
I'm kind of like no wait don't like
don't let Disney rot itself to the core
okay we'll make we'll make our own show
with Ian that's right and no hooker and
bucko yeah we're just talking today
about a lot of content is like people
are are creating like Christian content
like there's pure flicks which is
starting to ramp up the Hallmark has
their own daily wires I never heard that
pure flicks been around since 2005 but
people don't want to be bashed over
their head with it so you've got to
figure out what's the next phase and I
think the next phase is sci-fi that
takes into account like the cosmology
and this new physics where we're finding
like Cosmic microwave background
radiation that kind of looks like
neurons in the brain and you're like wow
maybe there is a God and if you can kind
of take people in that direction you
know you can kind of bring God into the
conversation and kind of ground it in
like morality but still have cool sci-fi
message on top of that I mean the whole
thing kind of depresses me because I
remember there was a time where there it
wasn't like right content or left
content you know it was content like a
movie or a show or whatever you know was
about you know whatever the topic of the
day was or but it wasn't like you
watched a show or a host or whatever
because they had a specific view it was
you know you came on you had discussions
about complex topics and people got into
it and they could disagree and that was
acceptable and I definitely feel like
um and you know full disclosure like I
said earlier I'm moderate
um I do feel like if you're a
conservative you know
you have fewer opportunities to have
your voice heard and you see it in
businesses like I have friends that own
um you know whether they're Second
Amendment businesses or or 2A adjacent
like I have a friend that owns a company
called fieldcraft survival Mike Glover
oh yeah we love Mike he was on the show
yeah a few months Mike's Mike's amazing
I mean he's one of the best people I've
ever met and
um you know he's essentially you know
targeted as almost a domestic terrorist
and it's insane this is a guy that you
know served you know in Special Forces
you know I have not found a single human
being that doesn't like him and you know
the special operations in military
Community is a lot like a sorority where
people like to talk about each other you
know there's a lot of that like
everybody's got a little bit of a beef
with everybody no one has said anything
about Mike Glover everybody's like he's
the best dude on planet Earth
and his content is constantly you know
pulled down and he's just telling people
how to survive in a crisis and didn't
defend the feds attack him and label him
like a domestic yeah yeah what was that
what was the story explain it to people
because that's a big one yeah he he is
on a list like field Craft Survival Mike
Glover they're on a list as like
potential domestic terrorists and like
this guy would never do anything against
this country like I mean he he is a you
know and people throw this term around
for people that don't deserve it like
he's a true patriot
um and uh I mean you know he's he's a
big part of uh Tim Kennedy's life who
who's you know been a friend of mine for
years
um you know I know him personally all of
my friends have worked with him or you
know in whether in the military or
business and this is a guy that's like
he owns a survival company so he teaches
you you know to shoot to hunt to you
know dress wounds to live in the wild
that's what he loves doing so that's
what he teaches people to do like how do
you survive in the worst possible
situation and um
yeah like you know he's been flagged and
it's wild to me like there's no undoing
it either well let's let's jump to this
next story here and we'll get into
what's going on with this stuff
The Washington Post career prosecutors
recommend no charges for Matt gates in
sex trafficking probe investigators see
credibility challenges for two main
Witnesses in a probe of the Congress
men's alleged past dealings with a then
17 year old in other words there's no
evidence there's nothing that's it just
some people with no credibility making
accusations they can't back up and so
the prosecutors are like ain't nothing
we can do about it we'll see they're
saying maybe they'll still bring charges
but it'll be extremely unlikely to do so
considering what they're saying now but
here's what happened they start the
probe someone leaks information to the
press and then all of a sudden it's it's
it's law the media just says it's
happening and that's what they do so my
question is with everything we've seen
with the FBI the Washington field office
particularly going after their political
Rivals how much of this was an extortion
plot how much it was it was because
let's let's just show you the context
here this is from Politico Florida man
gets five years in plot to extort Matt
Gates's father a U.S District Judge
sentenced Stephen Alford to 63 months
plus three years supervised release the
story he went to the family and said hey
I can make that all go away if you give
me 25 million dollars so I'm starting to
lean towards whoever set this up the
investigators and then whoever was
leaking it they were all in on it
what do you think from your information
yeah I don't you know to me like I don't
have information so like I don't I I'm
very careful like I don't like to Lobby
uh lob accusations or you know at people
that where I don't have real information
so I will say that you know I my
instinct was that it was true based on
the coverage from every major paper you
know I believe them and what's that well
I believe them well at six point
especially so you know
the last you know couple years of my
life dealing with some of the uh some of
the things I've dealt with definitely
has me questioning a lot more things
I'll say that but you know typically The
Washington Post does a pretty good job
you know disagree you know my opinion my
opinion David Weigel fabricated a story
and they and then they secretly edited
it six months later and they never they
never like they never issued a public
correction he literally just wrote a
fake story about the Seth Rich
conspiracy Matt manufactured insane
claims that made no sense and then I
actually get him on the phone and this
is at the Washington Post and I'm like
you made this up and he's like okay and
then nothing happens six months later
they go in without saying anything and
they alter it to clean it up and that's
it no official correction no public
statements or anything The Washington
Post is just garbage and that's just the
easy example like at the top of my head
I'm sure there's I'm sure there's plenty
of examples everywhere but this is them
right now saying no charges no I see it
yeah yeah I mean you know so who are
these other options and I will say that
I will say that you know if when all is
said and done it comes out that you know
this guy is innocent I mean that that's
pretty terrible but he was always
innocent
but I mean everyone's innocent until
proven guilty right exactly so you know
so they just run fake stories in the
Press what they they play dirty games
like
these these liberals tend to think that
if you're accused of a crime you're
guilty of it that's a terrifying reality
well that that is the way the media
works right so like there's been a huge
Dynamic shift where you know it used to
be that like journalists took a long
period of time to get stories out make
sure that they had sources confirmed all
of them now because of the age we're in
where everyone is is creating news
quickly you know including like you guys
right
um it is a race to get the story first
which often means that the story is
inaccurate and once somebody launches
the story everybody races to tell the
same story and you end up getting this
confirmation bias yeah but this is
something different I mean this is
people leaking information on a story
that had no evidence or credibility sure
and in the media especially leftists
running it as if it was true yep I mean
let's be honest here there's a lot of
sex traffickers in Washington DC there's
no denying that there's a lot of sex
traffickers everywhere exactly yeah and
and it's important to note here that the
FBI has been moving according to the
latest whistleblowers agents off of
those cases and moving them on to the
January sixth cases and when it came to
this particular case I did find it
interesting because I I do follow a lot
of these stories I think they're
important to talk about especially when
it comes to things like the DC Madam
that's a whole nother crazy story that
if you want to go down a rabbit hole you
could go down a rabbit hole with but but
I didn't find any any evidence here with
Matt Gates I didn't see anything
legitimate I didn't see anything
confirmed so I kind of kept quiet about
it I waited as a journalist to see what
was going to be happening what was going
to be developing here but online all
over Reddit there was number one posts
calling him a sex trafficker sure but I
haven't seen anything legitimate I
haven't seen any evidence suggesting
this but everywhere on social media
especially in leftist circles he is
automatically deemed now a sex
trafficker which I think is a little bit
unfair since of course there's no
evidence providing this this assertion
which was spread out by you know
insiders from the government and then
regurgitated by the corporate media to
smear somebody
yeah I mean I think there's always a
bias against people you don't like if
you don't like somebody it's very easy
to believe bad things about them exactly
and you know and he's uh extremely far
right and you know is is a continuous
Target I I just can't help feeling like
this is a classic case of we were
talking about innocence until proven
guilt this is a case of the media
choosing whether to decide if someone is
guilty or not and going with it they
don't care about whether it's actually
true then if it's proven that they're
wrong they simply don't talk about it
I've seen them do this before so what
happens if they're if it's proven that
they're they've been lying or they've
been inaccurate or they've left
something out they just stop talking
about it I agree with you like I'm
genuinely surprised I'm proud of the
Washington Post for talking about this
at all like good for them but because
what they like to do is just swoop it
under the rug like Tim was saying with
this other story that after six months
months they went back and sneakily
edited it and didn't say anything about
it yep I think still to this day they've
never fixed it really yeah it's amazing
and now will there be a major retraction
from all these other organizations that
slandered him will all the people who
made fun of them
the activists are already saying stuff
like
you know they just they know they can't
win but it doesn't mean it's not true
yeah I mean like there's traffickers and
you know this because there's there's
victims coming forward Epstein had his
victims coming forward to the FBI in the
90s and there was people speaking out
against this and of course they didn't
do anything about it where's the victims
of gates coming forward like who is that
guy who um he called out Epstein nobody
nobody believed him uh what was his name
you know Luke gradkowski no no no no he
had a big show
big information and he's he's in court
right now and it's kind of a show trial
or Alex Jones oh dude you got to see the
most recent clip of him going at it with
the lawyer who's like Target the lawyer
is whining really hard and Alex was like
so some base stuff it's pretty uh yo The
Alex Jones trial is hilarious there's
this clip I was watching it I was
watching the live stream of it and the
plaintiff's attorney asked him who he
gets his sales reports from and then
Alex is like uh
uh no no one and then he's like no who's
it who's giving it to you and then he's
like I'm not allowed to say and so then
they have to call like sidebar and the
judge actually says you are right to do
that because he would have to say it's
coming from the bankruptcy lawyers so
like the rulings against Alex are
actually inhibiting the plaintiff's
attorneys and then there was that other
clip that went viral where he said you
know he mentioned liberals morals
turning on a dime or whatever and all
the Iraqis they killed their lies yeah
the guy the lawyer was getting really
emotional and spring he's like you do
it's emotional when you want to be
emotional it's not when you don't I'm
sorry I gotta say about people's lives
being lost I gotta say the judge is
inadequate I'm being polite inadequate
I'm being applied to the judge because
when the plaintiff's lawyer starts like
just yelling at Jones and Jones starts
snarking back the judge did nothing and
then another lawyer was like judge are
you gonna do this doesn't mean she goes
well I can't get a word in edgewise it's
like you're the you have a bailiff
you're a judge you can bang the gavel
and hold people in contempt and you're
sitting there letting people mouth off
it's all for TV you have responsibility
to do that as a Justice that's your
courtroom
whatever it's all for TV it was it we're
getting memes out of it and the videos
are funny and it's just all it's like
you know I'm watching that and uh uh I
can't remember who said it but they said
that the January 6 hearings are
basically like nightly entertainment for
wine moms they're like sitting there
going like oh what's gonna happen next
oh he did what and then they're voting
based on it it's kind of scary it is
yeah but it's it's more because it's
like if the FBI really is moving
Manpower out of like sex trafficking and
going into domestic terrorism I kind of
wonder what you think about this Nick
like why do you think that this is
happening do you I mean do you do you
think there's actually
um a risk of domestic terrorism
overthrowing American republicanism
no I I don't I mean you know I don't
think January 6th was a good thing I
don't think I think that people should
be held accountable so just you know
that that's my my position on that
um do I think that it was uh you know
like a big planned Professional Event
like I do not I I think it was a bunch
of idiots doing idiot things and
um humbling about you know what are they
called the Maga mimos yeah like I mean
like you know you look at that group and
like you know these people are not you
know this is not uh
you know like James Madison and and John
Adams I mean like that like that's not
what you had yeah this wasn't SEAL Teams
moving in um
you know yeah I mean you know it's a big
deal and I don't I think it should be
taken seriously
um but I I also don't think I think that
the press this is where I really get
aggravated with the Press we talk a lot
about Civil War right and I I think that
these people don't know what Civil War
is or they think it won't happen but
they think they can get clicks by
talking about it but you know there are
going to be idiots that start believing
that there's like a real Civil War
that's forthcoming and you know
why wouldn't there be
why wouldn't there be
um
because
I'm not saying it can't happen because
it can happen anywhere
um I think that
Americans do not really want to
shoot their neighbor in the face what
about the guy in North Dakota who just
took an SUV and ran over an 18 year old
oh yeah no listen no and and when you
when you talk about stuff like that
where you have people that have been
driven to a point where they truly
believe that like someone is the enemy
because they're a Republican or a
Democrat like that's a real problem and
the president did just give a speech
where he said that
yeah I thought I thought that was an
ill-advised you know but don't you like
don't you kind of think for one I'd say
this is what I was saying about Bill
Burr when he said people don't hate each
other it's the internet I'm like yeah
why would a neighbor want to shoot their
own neighbor yeah well no because people
who live next to each other tend to
share political values but what about
the person who lives in a city talking
about somebody who lives in themselves
that's not necessarily like I live in
Chapel Hill which is like the most
liberal place on Earth right Chapel Hill
North Carolina
um and I like actually I have a funny
story like one day I I answered the door
for the pizza guy and I was wearing like
a second amendment t-shirt and the dude
started I'm crying he's like oh my God
like there's there's another like
conservative in this town you know I
thought that was really funny my
neighbors are great they're they're all
liberal they're great people they're
nice people and so anytime anybody
starts talking about Civil War I
literally asked I'm like do you actually
want to shoot your neighbor in the face
well nobody wants to but but what are
you gonna do it for like what's the up
you're if we have a civil war in America
our life here will never be as good as
it is now your life will be worse will
absolutely be be worse for the rest of
your life that's true you know there
will be like catastrophic I mean like
people here do not understand all right
all right let me ask you then
um how many child sex changes would you
allow to happen
uh like like so like period so so uh no
where you live right yeah you know it's
very liberal yeah uh let's use
Vanderbilt for example in Tennessee
they've been giving children sex change
surgery you'd be willing to compromise
on that to to allow
well I want to start by like
like I am totally supportive of anybody
that's trans like I I am I am totally
fine with an adult you know deciding
that like this is not who they want to
be
um I I treat anybody with empathy I will
treat anybody with respect if you you
know if you were a man and you
transitioned to being a woman like I
will call you by your new name I will
always be kind to anybody and I think
that's it's totally acceptable
um I do get nervous but I am also not an
expert in this I do get nervous anytime
you're talking about children given that
you know there is a high percentage of
folks that trans that begin
transitioning and then change their mind
resistance which is uh depending on the
study it can be between 65 and like 95
so
you know I I think that
um you you just have to be careful I
made this point to Stephen Marsh he
wrote a book called The the next civil
war
and you know he was saying he believed a
civil war's coming he wrote a book about
it but he's more on the liberal side
though he doesn't think he is he doesn't
realize that he is and we talked about
it he's a cool dude we just disagree and
uh you know I pointed out to him I said
you have Universal Health Care in Canada
he's Canadian he said yes and I said
okay
um we don't hear would you give up half
of your how much of your health care
would you give up to compromise so that
we don't go into conflict and he goes I
wouldn't and I'm like you see there's a
problem don't you so what we're having
now is sure you might say like why would
a neighbor fight a neighbor well they
probably wouldn't I mean in many Civil
Wars regular people are trying to flee
from the violence you take a look at
Syria you take a look at the Arab Spring
you take a look at Ukraine most people
are just leaving but a lot of people are
fighting now when it comes to Ukraine
it's different that's an invasion that I
understand when you look at Syria there
are people who are choosing to fight and
fight for their cause so the issue I see
is it may be that 90 of people don't
want to fight and that's a good thing
because they shouldn't want to fight
nobody should but then you come to an
impasse and the impasse right now is
Stark Matt Walsh just did this big
expose on Vanderbilt University in uh I
think they're in Nashville right the
medical center and they have videos
talking about how much money they're
going to make doing sex change
operations on on children on actual
children irreversible damage
irreversible surgeries and the issue I
take with this is not have anything to
do with trans people because I agree
with you on that on that point you know
people I think if they're adults should
be free to um do what their bodies as
they see fit within certain reason of
course I mean we don't want people
harming themselves like committing
suicide and there's question about
questions about body dysmorphia but the
issue here is the scientific studies
showing High rates of desistance and you
look at our Scandinavian more
Progressive friends over in Europe and
they've shut down this this stuff so now
you have the issue of
billboard Chris are you familiar with
billboard Chris I am not he wears a
billboard that says children cannot
consent to puberty blockers and when he
goes up and he talks about this stuff
plainly calmly scientific reports
trusting the science they scream in his
face they threaten him in some instances
they stalk him and then we've actually
seen what happens when you go against a
lot of this ideology I mean one kid in
North Dakota for being a republican
extremist apparently and threatening the
guy so claims the guy he's dead now and
the guy killed him and fled the scene so
the issue that arises is in Florida for
instance
yeah uh Rhonda Santos and I'm sure many
people around him will say hey schools
shouldn't be giving kids sexy sex ed
without parental consent so what does
the media do completely lie about
everything happening
you've got Boston Children's Hospital
and this whole hoax around a bomb threat
the threat was really called in it was
called into the hospital but the media
was reporting that there was an
evacuation when there wasn't and it's a
complicated story and then you have
Vanderbilt
with all of these institutions once
they're exposed giving children sex
change operations they delete their
their websites and I think it's obvious
they know that the overall majority of
American people would reject that and
are horrified by the idea that they
would do it and so then you have people
saying look
you know there are people who believe
nothing's going to happen meanwhile the
violence has been escalating
consistently for several years you've
got Joe Biden coming out on TV only a
few weeks ago saying that my Republicans
are an extremist threat to this country
two weeks later a guy kills a kid for
calling it and calls him a republican
extremist so you you combine these
things with even look outside of my
opinion it's my opinion is all based on
Expert testimony a Princeton Professor
saying that there's a cold Civil War
coming
all all signs I should say the history
of what we're missing today rhymes with
what we've seen in say Russia Spain or
or Germany so for for people to come out
the way I described it the other day is
you know when Bill Burr comes out and
says neighbors aren't fighting each
other we're sitting atop a watchtower
checking the news reading the news all
day every day and we can see pockets of
conflict all off in the distance and
then we can literally see the president
stand up on a Podium and yell they are
the enemy and they're destroying this
country and then we look down in the
ground where Bill Burr's having a beer
and he goes nobody's fighting anywhere
there's no Civil War over here you're
crazy so when I hear that kind of stuff
I'm like that was a good Bill Burr oh
thank you thank you but I I just you
know considering we we talk about it
I don't think any I don't think like no
one here that we've ever had wants a
Civil War and so we have people like
Michael malice and even Luke saying
National divorce peaceful divorce before
it gets to that point but you actually
have memes emerging about the country
splitting up and
there was a survey done I believe it was
yougov data that surveyed uh every uh
survey like a thousand some other people
in each region there were five regions
there's the West there's the South
there's the Heartland there's the
Midwest or I think the northeast or
whatever I don't know how they broke it
up the mountain region I think it was
and found that in the South something
like 60 of Republicans want to secede as
a self in the Northeast the majority of
Democrats want to secede in the west the
majority of Democrats want to secede in
the mountain region I think it was a
plural I shouldn't say majority a
plurality it was a majority of
Republicans it was like 60 of the South
and then it was a plurality in the east
and west of Democrats the Midwest area
was surprising the Heartland as they
called it that was uh the plurality was
independent voters one in Mississippi
overall if I did the math I broke down
the the total the total uh I took each
State's population I took the total
number of people pulled broke it all
down
37.2 percent of people in the United
States would favor their region
separating from the United States so
when you have metrics like that and
consistently pull after pull after poll
saying people expect it to happen at a
certain point you're like yo we're
knocking at the door it's it's
something's happening yeah I mean so you
know I don't think the federal
government's going to allow that and I
also think that people don't really what
does that mean you know what it means I
mean like there's like we're not going
to allow states to secede from the union
that's gonna that would actually be War
so I don't think that that I don't think
that's going to happen I also don't
think people know what the economic
impact of that kind of separation would
be on on every region every region I
don't think anyone does it calculating
what's going to happen I think if you
look at the history of Civil Wars around
the world no I get it it's ideological
and tribal and it happens I get it so
how would the federal government stop
you know they would they would
absolutely use Force I mean there's no
like it's not going to happen you think
the federal government has enough
Personnel especially at record low
recruitment rates to deal with national
National Conflict at this level that's a
good question they absolutely don't the
Civil War in uh 1861 the country was
substantial smaller and some of the
fighting didn't even reach other parts
other territories in the United States
and a lot of the fighting was confined
to like the southeast specifically so
what happens I'll put it this way the
American Civil War is not indicative of
civil of of of both Civil Wars it was a
really weird unique thing where a
separate Union formed and those two
unions wanted each other but if you look
at the Syrian Civil War for instance
where you have 12 different factions now
you take a look at the polarization
United States and you actually have
three or four factions maybe even more
depending on how far you want to break
it down so you have yes I hear what
you're saying I just the economic hit
that everybody would take like lives
changing forever and then you have the
sub question of all right so like you
know just because
uh you know let's say California says we
want to secede right that's the most
obvious one we know California's primary
primarily liberal but still you know
it's still like 40 percent conservative
and so now you have all these people
that are that are trapped essentially in
California like it's just it's a bad
scene no matter how you look at it I
don't think there are some people who
absolutely want to happen but I think
the overall majority of people don't
want it to happen and even as I or
Stephen Marsh or uh I don't know who
else has has talked about this to to
Great degrees I mean you've got a CBS
reporter recently coming out saying
civil war is coming MSNBC on prime time
TV says we're in it already a Princeton
Professor is saying we've been in it for
four years none of them are saying it's
a good thing so we all agree it's not a
good thing but that doesn't mean it's
not happening yeah so you know I would
I'd maybe consider that we have you know
what you called it I thought that was
good a cold Civil War I think there's
definitely like some ideological
questions happening I do not and and I
don't want this to sound bad because I
love this country and I you know I love
I think it's the best country on Earth
I've been to 56 countries so like I have
some you know some knowledge of of what
that means I don't think Americans in
general are willing to pay the price for
what they believe
right but like most people fleeing
Ukraine the majority tend not to fight I
mean even in the American Revolution I
mean Ukraine is the but if you look at
the the American Civil War that one was
particularly interesting because people
really were willing to fight on the
North you had you had uh people who
wanted to preserve the union who are
fighting just because they were enlisted
but there were a lot of abolitionists
absolutely Christian wasn't even
American he was like I'm fighting stop
this stuff yeah and that was a uniquely
American thing
um you know our our spirit is different
than the rest of the world I don't see
that in the average person anymore but I
mean if people are mildly inconvenienced
the average person doesn't fight never
has in any War but you're kind of seeing
a lot of people as as yourself you're
thinking of the long-term consequences
and I think a lot of people have been
taught not to think think about the
long-term consequences a lot of people
are reactionary a lot of people have
been you know thought through social
media that emotions you know matter or
more than of course any kind of logical
thinking Frederick Nietzsche has this
great quote that I talked about a couple
days ago on the show he says in
individuals insanity is rare but in
groups parties Nations and epochs it is
the rule so so I I think it's it's worth
noting that that we are on the precipice
where our mindsets are being controlled
by big Tech social media there is I
would say a divide and conquer agenda I
would say people are are acting against
each other more and more I think a lot
of this is deliberate and it doesn't
have to mean States go against States it
could mean groups and organizations go
against other groups and organizations I
just I just think you know you got a
case in Texas where a man and woman get
divorced the mother claims the kid is
trans the father claims the kid is not
and the state Awards the kid to the
mother
you don't think that you're gonna get to
the point where a father just says no
sure but that's not that's not a civil
war that's an individual matter no
that's that's like Civil Wars don't
start because one guy no I understand so
Civil Wars start when an ideology
becomes persistent when the state begins
taking children away from from parents
and they and they are now and you're
seeing this in uh you know conservatives
of course are calling it out they're
saying this is actually uh I can't
remember who I was watching but they
there was a conversation happening they
said parents are afraid that if they
speak up their their children will be
taken from them schools in many places
are telling the children not to talk to
their parents teachers are posting
videos saying parents have no right to
educate their children or know what's
going on I know it's ideological and
it's pervasive at what point do we see
like with the bundies right the bundies
actually had arms
I don't know I want to push back a
little bit I don't know that it's
pervasive I think it is a problem in
some school systems in some places you
know I don't think it's pervasive like I
I do not think that exists for example
where I live in Chapel Hill like and
that's a it's a very
I mean I'm pretty involved with with my
kids I'm pretty involved with the school
system my wife is very involved with the
school system but does this mean that
you've gone and checked the curriculum
for the books that they're giving to
kids like we have one right here that
has sexual depictions in it and it's in
school libraries and we had uh who was
it Omani yeah their name she wrote a
whole bunch of them she came in with a
stack of 50 or 60 books that have
appeared in schools all over the all
over the entire country and uh yeah
parents aren't checking these things so
to be like I don't think it's that but
as a maximum Freedom guy yourself isn't
that on the parents
you know I'm also not afraid of but this
is why Glenn youngin yeah well are you
afraid of porn in front of children yes
right so that's the problem no one's
talking about a book we're talking about
in this book gender career sitting right
on this table there's a depiction of
someone several depictions of sexual
activity Amazon listed as 18 and plus 18
and over only but they're putting it in
school children's libraries and they've
done it several times yeah so it is a
persistent ideology and that's why it's
become so shocking and such a powerful
political issue that's why even Bill
Maher addressed the concept just the
other just just last week saying
Democrats need to stop this and that's
why it's so crazy that Matt Walsh he
highlights Vanderbilt University
bragging about how much money they're
going to make doing these these
irreversible surgeries Vanderbilt pulls
the website down clearly they know it's
shocking but then you see leftists
anti-fun in the media use all of their
power and resources to try and shut the
idea down you see people getting banned
and suspended over talking about it so
it this is a high level issue but it's
also an issue that makes people people
really really angry yep and it's it's
pushing us to the edge yeah but it's not
just that no but I mean look but I mean
let's just put it simply the FBI just
served subpoenas on 40 plus Trump uh uh
uh supporters Steve bannon's been
charged Leticia James couldn't even get
criminal charges on Trump as now filing
a civil suit against them the the power
of the federal government is being used
against Trump supporters to the extent
that the president would go on TV and
say half the country are an extremist
threat and then someone would run over
and kill a kid so I'm telling you so no
like I'm I'm totally with you that
speech that speech was inappropriate I
do want to just go back to the like I
have a much more optimistic view of the
world than you do
um but what's what's pessimistic about
what I'm saying because I I think like
with this book right I I 100 think that
there are people bad people out there
that want to you know get their
worldview across I think most people you
know whether it's this book or other
books I think most people are trying to
be empathetic to kids that might be
different whether you know they're
they're gay or they're bisexual or
they're figuring it out or whatever and
I think I think that this generation is
very empathetic compared to my
generation when I grew up you know like
if somebody was gay they got made fun of
if somebody was even an offense
I do I do want to I want to finish the
thought right and so it's entirely
possible people are looking at this and
you know most people are bad at their
jobs right like I mean at best most
people are average and so like they
might have looked at this and said like
you know oh this is one of the school
books that that's out there not read it
not looked at the material and thought
hey this is an empathetic book like I'm
not saying that that's the case I don't
know but I just do not believe that
there is like a universal group of
people that are trying to show kids
pornography I think that in general
terms people are trying to say like hey
you know what maybe like you know when
we were younger we did not treat people
that were different well and we would
like to and maybe they're not doing
their job well they're not looking at
they're not doing their homework they're
not making sure that it's
age-appropriate content we should always
be you know respectful of of other
people and their differences of course
obviously but what are the consequences
of these actions in our schools what are
the consequences of what's happening in
Canada right now where these policies
have led to children being taken away
from their parents because their parents
aren't transitioning their children and
and and again we have to be careful what
we say here how is it empathetic where
in Canada right now parents are having
their children taken away from them
because they don't transition them
yeah that and that's a different
situation and like I'm sure but that's
what it led to I understand well
yeah I understand where you're coming
from but I mean here's here's just
another important factor like perhaps
you're correct perhaps there are a lot
of people who don't know what they're
putting in front of children and don't
care enough to actually do it I don't
see how that's empathy I don't see how
it's empathy to be alike sure do the
book whatever I don't know what's in it
empathy would be like let's keep our
kids safe and happy no no I'm saying
empathy how is it a double mastectomy on
a 13 year old girl empathy yeah no I
agree with you there so why are there
people actively defending that and
calling Matt Walsh an extremist for
saying hey maybe we shouldn't do that
like listen my point here is it doesn't
matter what whether you agree with it or
don't this the the the concept of
sterilizing a child or permanently
removing the breast tissue of a 13 14 or
15 year old girl is considered an
atrocity we used to consider female
female genitals we used to have huge
stories about female genital mutilation
being wrong now you have universities
actively promoting it so if you can
consider that a conservative did not
leave that space and Vanderbilt
University is saying there are instances
where we will mutilate the chests or
secondary sexual characteristics or give
give other uh puberty blockers and
chemicals that aren't approved for this
to children
we're in the territory now where there's
a group of people for whatever reason
doesn't matter are advocating atrocities
against children
yes so I I'm I think you always are
going to have a problem with
extreme capitalism and what I mean by
that are you know there are people that
are willing to make money doing anything
and so you know when you again I I'm not
educated on the story so I want to be
very careful with what I say here but
you know if if that is the case if if
there is a organization that is excited
about making a ton of money you know
providing those Services that's
obviously a problem that's not medical
care that is malintent
um I also agree with you like as I said
earlier you know I don't think children
should be making these decisions I you
know I certainly don't think unless
there's abuse from the parent or
something if it's a situation where the
parent is you know ridiculing the kid or
something because the kid is trans or
you know believes that you know he or
she is trans then I think that is a
different problem so like I think you
have to look at every case individually
if there are bad people involved that's
one thing now if it's just uh you know a
a parent that doesn't think that it's
appropriate you know I think that is a
that is a much different situation are
you okay with the drag queen Story Time
and the videos that are coming out
showing you know it's not going to lick
itself yeah and and you know people
stripping in front of children and
children giving them dollars or children
stripping how about the children
strippers I am I am not okay with
anything sexual being provided to
children that will that be I want no but
I want to be clear because there's so
many
like if if there is a trans teacher
I don't I have no problem with that if
it is a sexualized situation like a show
I do have a problem what about that yeah
I mean I I that's like that's a
ridiculous but this is protected this is
so this is in Canada just so you know
yeah uh which is not the same but uh
under the same legal language yes right
yeah I understand now look I don't I
don't care to get in like I I don't want
to go overboard with just talking about
the kids and stuff I think there's
better examples are you familiar with
the story of The Bundys the Bundy Ranch
and all that stuff and yeah of Land
Management yes uh so what we saw there
you had people armed with rifles on
Bridges pointing them let's just say in
the direction of federal agents yep and
that was what that was what seven eight
years ago or maybe even longer eight or
nine years ago so when you see things
like that we know it's possible
and then my issue is
Cal Rittenhouse
in his own in his own town
uh goes out provides medical assistance
and is armed someone threatens to kill
him several times he runs someone fires
a gun in the air brain house turns
around the guy then lunges for his gun
and nearly grabs it writtenhouse fires
clearly in self-defense as as the jury
found
and then he flees to the police he's
attacked with the skateboard knocked
over a man with I think Glock tries to
shoot him Kyle right now goes to jail
for 80 some odd days I believe he's
vilified in the Press he's called the
white supremacist they lie in every
every step of the way demonizing him and
they still do it to this day and now
they're still going after him
this guy uh in North Dakota ran over a
teenager killing him he's out on bond
like that no media coverage no question
in the Summer of Love in May of 2020
black lives matter and antifa ransacked
almost every city in this country I mean
it's insane you get Michael Tracy's
reporting small towns you never heard of
had rioting several dozen are dead
Kamala Harris provides she fundraises to
get these people out of jail Joe Biden's
staff personally pay to get people out
of jail
and then you have the 529 Insurrection
when far left extremists tore down the
barricades in front of the White House
set fire to Saint John's Church Set Fire
to the guard post in front of the White
House and forced the president in the
into a bunker now why was it that story
which is I believe that was what two
that was two years ago why wasn't that
an Insurrection why isn't that story
like maybe when you know a few thousand
far left extremists set fire to a church
and tried to firebomb the White House
and the president's forced in a bunker
maybe the ideology has reached a point
where we're on the we're getting
dangerously close to the Civil War now
here's now here's here's the kicker
years ago people kept saying like you
said to me now the federal government
would never allow it but the federal
government is clearly split between
these exact factions Stephen friend and
um this other was Kyle Serafin seraphin
FBI agents blowing the whistle calling
out the actions the corruption and the
political bias in the in in the doj and
then you actually have the FBI uh that's
being called out acting at the behest of
Democrats towards political ends so
maybe it's just a bunch of wild crazy
extremists fighting each other in the
street Aaron Danielson getting shot
twice in the chest uh far left
extremists firebombing churches and you
know pregnancy centers all over the
country
oh actually they're in the doj and
they're using the power of the federal
government and then when that doesn't
work you get the AG in New York filing
try attempting to file charges against
Trump when that doesn't work they go
after a civil suit what we're
experiencing is not just cold Civil War
it's fifth generational Civil War the
fact that YouTube two weeks ago
announced they're going to be
suppressing information they deem
borderline is election manipulation the
fact that the FBI said they the
whistleblowers pointed out they were
instructed not to investigate Hunter
Biden's laptop I mean maybe you're right
maybe they'll be a Civil War and only
because A revolution is taking place and
extremists are taking over the
government and nothing's being done
there was there was a lot a lot in that
statement
um I will start I'll start with the part
that I 100 agree with I think that we're
at a situation now where big Tech has
too much power
um and you know I can't give you the
clean answer to what should happen there
but I think that the second that that
you are editorializing social media
there is a there is a problem
um and you know I mean look I'm fine
with I'm fine with very hard you know
like hey I don't I don't want like Nazi
propaganda on any of these things I
don't want you know like the like those
viewpoints
um out there because I think I think
that's problematic but outside of that
you know what about communist viewpoints
yeah I mean I mean like Communists are
great at killing people they're better
yes they're better than they're better
than anybody yeah um absolutely but do
we treat them the same way
yeah it's you know it's a valid question
right um I I think that I think people
need to be able to like I would much
rather have more voices out there and
more of those voices or voices that I
hate and despise and think are the worst
people on planet Earth then
have a giant Corporation decide who is
good and who is bad because even if
you're a good person like even let's
just let's just assume that Facebook is
trying to do the right thing for a
second
their opinions are not going to be your
opinions they're not going to be my
opinions and so now what we have is we
have a group of people that are all
essentially from California that grew up
with a certain Viewpoint that are
deciding what is appropriate speech now
I 100 understand that these are private
companies and they're you know they are
not
um regulated by the first amendment that
being said you know when they
essentially
control everyone's voice I mean like if
you if you take Facebook Instagram
YouTube Google I mean that is a huge
chunk of the internet so we know now
that the federal government has been
working directly with big Tech to censor
their political rights yes yep and I you
know the Facebook thing was I'm not
going to say it was shocking because uh
you know the the last you know year and
a half of working around government I I
definitely any dream I had that that our
government was The West Wing is gone
yeah no uh well I I just think that um
you know it was like four years ago yeah
when I was I was reading an article that
said Civil War is is likely they they I
can't remember who it was I think it was
the Atlantic they interviewed a bunch of
Security Experts and it said that uh it
was like 30 to 70 chance of a civil war
in the next decade and I was like Wow
and then what I ended up hearing from
all these conservative pundits was that
it would never happen because the
federal government wouldn't allow it
well lo and behold the federal
government has completely bifurcated at
this point with whistleblowers coming
out accusing the doj of corruption 20
plus and the doj itself overtly engaging
in partisan political activities I do
think and and you know this is one of
your things the the UNA party right I
think when it comes to certain things
the uniparty reign supreme I don't think
it's in either major political party's
best interest to allow a Civil War and
so I think that that is an instance
where you would have solidarity how
would they stop a civil war
I mean you know by force through
economic means there's a lot of stuff
but so let's break that down Force how
would that apply how would you stop a
Civil War by force I mean you use the
military you'd use police and what would
they do specifically
I think it depends on the situation
right at first it would be quelling
riots but you know I think what what
happens in uh in riots when the police
intervene people die the rights get
worse yeah yeah so uh my my fears are
that what might end up happening first
is that
two guys yeah in a small town in
Nebraska seeing what's going on just
walk up and put up a checkpoint that's
it and then someone calls and complains
but it's a it's a jurisdictional issue
it's a state level feds have no
authority to intervene at all one by one
you start seeing more instances like
what happened with the Bundy with the
Bundys and the Bureau of Land Management
yep more and more people in more rural
areas start saying no but it's always an
internal issue and the feds have no
Authority so the federal government
actually can't intervene when it comes
to State's issues well also the doj has
been politicized the military could be
politicized as well and many times when
there's historical Global civil
conflicts internally it's the military
fighting other military forces you know
Society is bifurcated but but I'm
curious on that point how the United
States would stop uh a you know civil
conflict or civil unrest especially with
its history in Vietnam and let's not kid
ourselves also Afghanistan where they
have failed
tremendously when it came to fighting
the Taliban which is now only that much
stronger and better well equipped after
trillions of dollars and 19 years of of
our soldiers going over there plus uh
morale is at an all-time low recruitment
levels are at record lows so if they
can't even stop guys with flip-flops how
are they going to stop guys you know
here in the United States again like I
mean you there's a jump that I think you
guys are making and uh listen you're all
smart people I'm not I'm not coming at
anybody I just think there is a huge
jump between
intermittent violence you know that is
being largely I think uh pushed by media
personalities because it's a hot button
topic everybody wants to talk about
Civil War I think just you know
constantly having this conversation is
even problematic because the crazy
people start believing that this has to
happen
um
I do not think most Americans have the
stomach or desire for it I think
fundamentally like but you're right
and I I think because of that reason I
do not think we will have
you know eight eight I don't want to say
real but a a real Civil War I don't I
don't think Syrian Civil War start
I mean it's always balkanization of
people
but it's always it's always a
balkanization of a you know oppressed
minority uh you know it it but this is
this is important yeah do you know how
the Syrian Civil War started well I mean
the Arab Spring obviously starts with
Tunisia um what was the guy's name was
it um
uh what's a fruit vendor it wasn't
Muhammad was easy was it I that sounds
very familiar he might have been a
journalist guy so in Syria you ended up
with uh following the suit of the Arab
Spring a bunch of Street protests
at least as it was reported because I
don't trust the the U.S reporting
apparatus in this regard considering the
U.S wanted to remove Bashar al-assar the
government started shooting at uh
protesters when the Government tried
quelling the unrest it became a civil
war so if we started getting widespread
rioting and protests on a greater scale
well it's entirely possible considering
the size of the United States if the
government did try to intervene it would
actually be what the cattle it would be
the Catalyst for the Civil War like it
was in Syria I think the problem
Americans have is that they think for
one like you keep saying Americans don't
want war of course they don't no one
ever did no one in any of these
countries Ever Wanted War but small
political factions started one and then
people's had their had their homes blown
up 90 plus percent of people just flee
and then the country crumbles
so what I see as being a terrifying
possibility is hyperpolarization
happened
because of covet and because of the
hyper the the social and political
polarization we're now seeing
geographical polarization for one we
left I left New York to South Jersey
left South Jersey to West Virginia
we're seeing a lot of that people
fleeing to Texas what's happening there
is that red areas are becoming red or
blue areas are becoming Bluer and this
has actually been happening for 30 or 40
years for sure the geographical uh
alignment for a civil war has been
occurring for decades now now you add on
hyper tribalization with the president
actually saying 74 million people are an
extremist threat
the powder Keg's been primed and ready
to go I mean you can't look like a
president coming on TV and giving an
address and they're cheering for it
these these Progressive and liberal
personalities are celebrating saying
good and they're calling for the
weaponization of the government of the
of law enforcement to go after their
political Rivals meanwhile the the
equivalent crimes committed by their
faction go unanswered and uh
I mean we're sitting on the edge of
something you can call whatever you want
but the the fear I have
there's an article written by the
bulwark and I certainly don't agree with
these guys but they wrote that it could
even be as soon as November 2022. now
part of me wants to have uh optimism
bias and say it's not possible or a
normalcy bias it just couldn't happen it
could never happen but their argument is
that
don't you think that all of these Trump
supporters and Republicans I believe
it's two-thirds of Republicans who
believe the election was stolen don't
you think they're going to go out to
these polling locations and they're
going to be surrounding them into
certain degrees just watching making
sure nothing bad happens and don't you
think antifa will also in in kind show
up to protest won't that lead to
fighting at polling stations what
happens if one fight happens at one
polling station and they're forced to
shut it down and then a large faction of
people aren't able to vote what happens
then when a court Challenge escalates
and they say the vote is illegitimate
because we weren't actually able to vote
and the court says we don't have a full
tabulation because a whole County of 400
000 people didn't vote what what if that
happens and those are that's
seemingly reasonable that's in line with
people saying oh we know the proud boys
and antifa fight okay what if divided a
polling place in November like you could
end up with even five polling locations
shutting down and lawsuits just halting
everything and then us getting no real
clear answer on the election that's
that's the bulwarks statement yep
yeah I mean you know
I mean you can game any scenario and you
know I think are those things possible
absolutely
I just think that there are a lot of
people in press that are profiting by
talking about this stuff and I don't
think it's as
uh widespread as you know the articles
in social media would have you believe
like I do not think that this is where
we're at right now I think that
politicians are incredibly disappointing
right now across the board I don't think
anybody right now has a vision of the
future I don't think anybody's trying to
say this is where I want to take America
this is how we get better this is how
you know we we kind of rise above it I
think that the easiest thing for
everybody to do is to just tell you know
talk about how the other organization is
terrible I agree with you that there is
an element of sensationalism to some
media coverage but I disagree with you
that this topic is problematic I think
this topic is important because I think
it's it's a big problem and if you
ignore a problem it only festers and
grows I think there is a big problem
between the left and the right and
Americans that are being divided and
Congress I'm not saying I'm not saying
that it should be ignored but it's to
the point where it's almost like Civil
War porn now like everybody do you know
how many times I've now seen like this
is what could happen these are the
things that might kick it off like
everyone's talking about it in a way
almost with excitement you know it's
great for clicks it's great for uh you
know sensationalism it's a great
headline but think about the logic there
for a second no I listen the logic's
there like again there's a lot of I mean
as uh earlier today uh I couldn't this
is a true story earlier today I went to
go pick up eggs because we have the
chickens I gotta grab the eggs and uh
you know when I came back to get back to
work I couldn't help but notice the
smell of
crap
and then I'm like oh that's weird so
what do you know what I did I looked at
my shoe sure enough there it was on my
boot that's why that's why I was my on
my shoe so I smelled it maybe the reason
you're seeing so much pop up about it is
because something's happening Now you
listen it's too much it's possible
listen I need to tell you what I think
yeah I think you have what's called a
normalcy bias and you know what that
means I do
you're saying all of these people are
doing it because it's good clicks and it
makes them money
maybe the reality is that's just your
normalcy bias certainly we couldn't
actually be facing a civil war certainly
the only reason they're doing it is
because it makes the money or there's
the other that people have been fighting
each other in the street for years now
the uh the elections have been
completely contentious 2016 they claimed
the Russians were involved and they
tried up holding up the electors 2020
same thing except that culminated in
January 6 which was absolutely insane
now you're actually to the point where
the president is going on TV and
demonizing half the country and then two
weeks later a guy murders a kid it's
like
you know Andy no gets gets gets just
brutally beaten covering a protest you
you can you can see the arrest uh the
trial of Alex Jones you can see it in
any any thing seemingly apolitical and
there is a political lens focused on it
you can see it in the Ukraine Ukraine
Gate scandal Donald Trump uncovered
corruption rather accidentally so they
impeached him for it Joe Biden actually
flies his son on Air Force 2 to China
for private Equity deals nothing happens
there there clearly is two distinct
realities doesn't matter who you support
or otherwise but this is literally
happening I think the reason you're
saying so much about it
MSNBC they I don't think it's an issue
of sensationalism for MSNBC to come out
and say this because they're four years
late to the party the stuff they're
talking about with violence in the
street was happening in 2016 and 2017
they're six years late to the party only
now they're talking about it yo I watch
people get the crap beaten out of them I
watch people make makeshift explosives
and throw them in Berkeley this stuff's
been escalating dramatically and now
we're to the point I remember telling
people they kept they keep saying
nothing's happening it won't happen then
a Dude shows up in Tacoma with a ghost
gun and fire bombs and tries firebombing
an ice facility and they're like that's
one crazy guy then you get a dude
walking up to another dude Aaron
Danielson in Portland seemingly at
seeking out a conservative and then you
hear we got one we got something like
that and then he shoots them twice in
the chest killing him this guy had a
communist tattoo on his neck if you're
going to look at all of these things
that are happening the grains of sand
being being added culminating with the
boulder of the president demonizing half
the country and then a murder following
it I just feel like you're choosing to
ignore it
no I'm not choosing to ignore it I think
all of these things are problematic I
just think if you look over the history
of our country we've had violence we've
had protests we've had you know all
kinds of issues and we've been able to
get through it and I I just am a more of
an optimist about the American people I
do not think that we are going to have
open Civil War I think that we are I
think we have a few more years of very
contentious political situation I think
we will have more violence I do agree
with you there but you know when you're
talking about Civil War when you're
talking about the end of the Union I
don't think we're there who's at the end
of the Union
well I mean the Civil War didn't end the
Union it preserved fair enough yeah fair
enough uh yeah and I and I don't agree
with the idea that it's pessimistic or
optimistic to uh uh to say that
something is happening perhaps it's
pessimistic if you were to say it's all
going to crumble down and be and that's
it it's over I think
something bad is going to happen but the
end result will be something you know
always something positive I think it's
more realistic for versus
I don't know it's not idealistic well I
think there also should be a concerted
effort to try to stop this divide I
think there should be an effort to try
to do this I agree when you look at the
corporate media's coverage it is amping
it up it is saying we need it they're
gonna attack us these people are gonna
come into your bedroom when you're
sleeping and you see this kind of this
kind of bombastic language from the
corporate media and in Independent Media
has been saying hey hey let's let's try
to stop this madness people are just
screaming there's a lot of insane people
that are getting on on on you know the
microphones getting on the major
communication highways but sadly big
Tech social media also elevates those
voices big Tech social media that of
course has connections to of course the
intelligence agencies that of course the
works on the beheads of the federal
government censors voices and and UPS
voices that of course uh they want to
promote and let's be honest from from
the last few years they have been
promoting drama they have been promoting
infighting they have been promoting the
most toxic voices that get the most
amount of attention that gets the most
amount of clicks some people say that's
that's because of monetary incentives
some people say that's because of a
larger agenda I think that's an agenda
that deserves to be called out no matter
what the uh real reason for it is but
they're censoring the right side of the
culture war and promoting the left side
regardless of whether it's you know on
the right you could you could make a
joke about something on TV that was
violent and they'll ban you for pushing
violence the left we see on Twitter they
actually post addresses to organize to
engage in violence and they get away
with it but I'll throw it back to 2019
when I was on the Joker experience with
the Twitter people and I said outright
if you keep doing this it's going to
result in something you know seriousness
violence and chaos and uh they did keep
doing it they still keep doing it
Facebook's now been exposed working with
the government to do it and what's
happened everything's gotten
substantially worse January 6 for
instance like I'm not saying January 6
was an Insurrection I think it was a
riot but it was a riot at the Capitol
that's why it was so bad I think the
violent people should be charged for it
but to act like that wasn't a
significant moment that as a dramatic
escalation so you know I'll put it this
way I've had people
who from back in 2018 would tell me I
was wrong now you know they'll come to
me and be like so I thought you said
something blah blah in 2018 and then I
go January 6. and they go oh yeah
yeah do you think it ends with January 6
you think all those Trump supporters are
just I don't I don't think it ends with
January so I do want to say like the the
difference between January 6th and all
of the other violence and and just to be
super clear I think it's absurd anytime
that we're like oh yeah it's no big deal
this violence was because so and so felt
this way or that way like no you don't
you don't get to just destroy property
murder people beat people up because
you're mad like that's that is not a
protest that is you know that is
something else
um and so you know I think in all of
those situations it's appropriate to
arrest people and you know and press
charges and whatever the violent ones
yes the violent ones exactly well yeah
so uh but I think the difference with
January 6th is it is literally people
trying to change the outcome of an
election and that is that that is the
precipice of a civil war
again I know what you're saying but it
is a small group of people doing an act
did that kick off you know a a host of
other violence throughout the country
like no it didn't did most people say
this was a good thing no they didn't
you know and and so I think that you
have to look at that there's always
going to be craziness
you know and you have you know as the
craziness escalated over the past decade
over the past decade yes is there is
there any reason to believe that that it
would stop
yeah I I think that people are tired of
the direction the country's going I I
think so I think that when you look at
you know I personally think some
supporters are going to be like you know
guys I don't want to I don't want to
argue anymore no I I don't I don't think
that but I I think that well so hold on
hold on let's let's try and walk through
this Trump supporters won't say okay I'm
done with this
Trump supporters are not going to say
that they're done with that are our
Democrats who hate Trump going to say
we're totally cool with Trump supporters
and winning elections no okay so there's
no sign of it slowing down no I I
disagree because I think that I think
Ron DeSantis is going to win the primary
I think he is more moderate than
president Trump I think he is less
aggressive towards people than president
Trump I think people do not want most
people do not want that level of
aggression in a president I think that
uh while the far left kind of applauded
Joe Biden's comments I think most people
including most Democrats were not super
pleased with a red background Emperor
situation you know calling out you know
you know however he called out Maga so
it's it's not exactly half the country
but it's a you know a third maybe I
don't think four million votes I don't
think that's I don't think that's
helpful you know I don't think that's
good and I don't think people want that
in general so if if uh you know when
when Biden did this prom all the biggest
names on social media cheered for it on
the left sure yeah and all the biggest
names in the right condemned it yeah my
question is if we've seen these factions
growing but those people don't represent
America they represent Trump gained 12
million new voters from 2016 to 2020.
his movement expanded dramatically and
his endorsement ratio is higher now than
it was in 2016 18 and 20 and 2020. he's
at what 92 percent so the Maga
Republican side has actually expanded
dramatically looking at these numbers
looking at the rhetoric and now the
escalation of violence and even
statements from the leader of the
Democratic Party
everything has escalated to it in a
substantial way like a snowball rolling
down a hill You could argue and I think
it's fair to say maybe right now it all
just stops who do I what do I know maybe
the Trump supporters are like man we
really don't want it you know what
keep the child sex changes
do mail-in voting we are just going to
let you do it I really see that it's
completely unlikely well in the inverse
Ron DeSantis maybe he can come out and
send more people to Martha's Vineyard
because we know how much they like that
oh I'm sorry they called him Hitler for
doing it they claim that he was a human
trafficker now he must be stopped
they're claiming he's worse than Trump
he's more tactful than Trump sure maybe
they'll just stop and say you know what
we're totally okay with Fascism and the
fascist taking over no I I don't see why
that's probable so if we're looking at
over the past decade
consistent escalation with the and I
think a lot of it has to do with the
millennial generation getting older and
gaining more power in government and in
corporations if we've seen escalation
and we see no signs of de-escalation
then if you're going to put down your
chips make your bet it would be on
escalation okay so maybe it's possible
that from here we don't go to Civil War
maybe we're still four years out maybe
it's eight years out maybe it's ten
years out who knows maybe we're just in
a precursor phase but either way so far
we have seen no signs of this slowing
down or reversing in any way
well I hope I'm right
I mean I gotta be honest I hope so too I
hope you're right too I I hope you're
absolutely because I'll tell you this
you know what I want more than anything
get a lounge we got a massage chair
downstairs I just want to turn it on
turn the TV on with you know maybe like
the X Games maybe some snowboarding get
a big old bucket of chicken wings and
let that be the day instead what we get
is I wake up in the morning and I see a
story about
crime murders sweeping these cities 200
murder increase in Portland there's a
crazy video right now I mean just after
the summer of love seeing all of these
bodegas just destroyed these small
businesses
watching these videos there's of people
randomly stabbing people in the street
all of it is dramatically escalated
seeing these videos of people open-air
drug markets in San Francisco it's not
just that it's political violence and
escalation it's that the economy is even
you know we're a year delayed on trying
to put up a steel frame building it's
just everything I've I've been seeing
over the past decade in every way
food prices inflation now we've got the
uh the Sterling the pound has collapsed
to near Dollar parity the Euros below
the dollar you've got war in Eastern
Europe Russia's conspiping Russia's
threatening nuclear weapons China's
firing missiles over Taiwan all of these
things just keep escalating I don't I
don't know if it's if I would call it um
in the law in the big picture
pessimistic to say these things are
happening because they're literally
happening and just because you think the
probability of such a thing would lead
to an escalation of it I don't think
that's pessimistic I suppose pessimistic
would be like we're all going to die in
our lives are ruined but I'm actually
fairly optimistic on all of it I think
bad things are happening but I think
it's going to make us stronger I think
we're going to be okay I think uh people
will find a way to survive and humans
will do what humans do best and adapt
and keep going
but first things
it's just gonna hit the fan family
friendly show here I think in some way
and I think there are a lot of
ingredients you know corporate media
social media the poor economic Outlook I
think all of that along with the
captured institution signals some major
troubles ahead I hope it gets uh figured
out I hope it gets better but there's a
lot of fuel being added to this fire but
back to the original point you know you
were in in Afghanistan the United States
couldn't stop that conflict how can they
stop a domestic conflict but but your
experiences in Afghanistan are also
probably that's a different situation
though right it's a different situation
where you know you have a different
culture and and you don't it's not it's
not your world you're trying to
influence someone else versus this is
who you are I I think California already
succeeded
effectively I mean they're they they've
outright said in over and over again
over the past two three decades they
won't abide by federal law they they use
illegal immigration as a means to
bolster their senses so they can get
extra power in the federal government I
believe in the last census uh they had
in the last decade they had one extra
electoral vote and Seton Congress due to
illegal immigrants that they allow in
sure and block the federal government
from enforcing the law so when you're
dealing with something like that
I mean you know what I'll just say one
last thing on it Texas filed a lawsuit I
think it was against Pennsylvania I
think 46 states signed onto that lawsuit
challenging the 2020 election I mean
that my friends is like dramatic Civil
War territory and Clarence Thomas and I
think Alito said it is our
responsibility to hear cases in the
original jurisdiction which is the
Supreme Court for the states but the
other justices said we will not and so
what ends up happening there is the
worst possible outcome
the people who said we have we have
Grievances and we demand a redress of
those grievances we're told over and
over and over again no
so that just makes desperate people take
desperate actions and that's what's
scary JFK said those who make peaceful
Revolution impossible make violent
revolution inevitable if they I I think
the fraud narrative is is just wrong
I think obviously there's questions
about certain things that happen there's
always some kind of fraud but I think
Trump lost because the media had
mobilized people because covid mobilized
people because covet hurt Trump trump
kept fouchy on a lot of things like that
but when people come and say we feel
like this is unfair and it's 74 million
voters almost half the voting block we
say
let's work out what's making you upset
and make sure we can come to an
agreement on how to move forward
instead all of the courts simply said no
we won't do it we won't even hear what
you have to say or look at anything
you're presenting almost all of the
court cases that were brought weren't
even on fraud they were on proceed
procedure and they were thrown out on
standing so these people didn't didn't
even get a chance to have someone say
your argument is wrong they outright
said we won't even bother with you
that's the kind of thing that results in
January 6 and then January 6 resulted in
people there are still people who
haven't even been charged with the crime
or in solitary confinement that's the
kind of thing that results in people
losing their minds
absolutely what a Friday yeah I hope
you're all entertained Civil War Fridays
yeah Civil War Fridays well anyway well
let's maybe try to focus on the more
positive aspects how can we prevent from
your from your you know intelligence and
and from your understanding what are
some positive things we could do to try
to bridge this Gap bridge this divide is
there anything even possible uh that
could that could help the American
people see that they have more in common
than they don't honestly I I'm a firm
believer that you invest in your
community and don't worry about the
national media apparatus
um and I know that sounds very simple
but you know I can get online and I can
give speeches and I can talk about
things and you know and people will
follow me and some people will hate me
and you know whatever it is but that
just becomes like the noise of the day
online what I can affect is I can donate
my time coaching I can donate my time to
ngos I can invest in my family my
children
my friends you know help people be part
of the community make the people around
me better I think fundamentally when
people focus on those things life gets
better and when people spend invest a
lot of time arguing online things do not
get better because arguing online gives
you the impression that like everything
is life or death like you know we've all
been there somebody pissed you off
online you end up spending two hours
arguing with some idiot on Twitter uh
you know and at the end of it you're
like you're amped and you're you know
you're frustrated and you're like what
did I just do you know and you get this
impression that like people are your
enemy but they're just bored online
they're aggravated by something you said
whereas and probably 14 years old and
possibly 14 years old um but
you know but in person I've literally
never had these kinds of aggressive
you know and I'm in a town where almost
everyone disagrees with like my
viewpoint you know certainly on you know
like the Second Amendment and some of
the other the other things but um I've
never had these aggressive conversations
the conversations are always reasonable
because they're in person you're looking
at somebody you're reading body language
you you realize that this person is you
know is coming from a good place you
know so if we're you know
I think in I think personal investment
in your community is the best thing you
can do and it doesn't it doesn't feel
the same it doesn't feel National it
doesn't feel like oh I'm changing the
world but the truth is you're going to
change the world more doing that than
trying to put out some you know message
to like save the day I certainly agree
with uh people should be taking care of
themselves their friends their families
working on themselves eating right
exercising and that'll dramatically
change their world for the positive
we got one we got one
no but but it's needed to have these
conversations I think you know your
perspective your point of view is
important to to to get into and to talk
and to have civil conversations about
and I think the more civil conversations
we have the better uh how do we you know
address the problems coming our way I
think you know they're very severe and
now that they are going to take us being
the best versions of ourselves being the
healthiest uh the most strongest
versions of ourselves because again
financially you know the situation is
also getting very oblique a lot of
people are going to get very desperate
and the thing that's going to protect
people is themselves as individuals and
their families the economy is always
critical the economy goes bad people are
unhappy I mean just in in
I'll say I'll say one thing too you know
earlier in that point when you were
saying that you think people are talking
about this because it gets clicks my
rebuttal was maybe it's because it's
actually happening but fair point my
perspective could be the broken one you
could be the one who's actually right
the media is just gamifying everything
and I'm seeing you know this hyper Focus
reality as well
maybe what the media is doing I'm sure
it's a little economy and a little
column B to be honest yeah
yeah hopefully the end result is people
you know chilling out one of the things
that we're doing with uh with our
website timcast.com is we're we only
have one political show technically too
but it's like Tim cast irl's
conversation and then my morning show
and the shows that we're creating
outside of this are you know Tales from
the inverted world is True Crime mystery
history pop culture crisis is pop
culture uh cast Castle Vlog is you know
Ian being crazy and silly and it's just
comedy and it's just apolitical because
I think that it's important we need to
make content that isn't in that space
for a variety of reasons we want to push
back against the woke weirdness but not
in a way where we're like making videos
where like wokeness is bad where yeah
sure no we just make shows that are
funny that happen to not be woke or you
know at least not overtly ridiculous I'm
gonna go to the bathroom oh thanks for
letting us know
but there's still you know a lot of
questions like how would you deal with a
drag queen Story Time coming to your
neighborhood would you do anything about
it would you try to maybe mobilize or
try to get the word out or how would you
deal with the situation like that in
like a again I think it depends on the
situation like I would want to know
exactly what's happening and assess like
if it's you know if it's a just a trans
person that is coming in to read I don't
have an issue with that if it is a
sexualized show then my child will not
be there what about a stripper yeah
definitely not a stripper but what if
they don't strip they're just like
wearing their stripper makeup and like
yeah none of that is well that's what
drag is
I understand what you're saying but a
lot of these stories online have said
drag show and it has not in fact been a
drag show well no no that's why I'm
asking off like if a stripper shut up
but didn't actually remove any clothing
would you be okay with the stripper
reading to your kids no I like they're
wearing any sexualized anything
sexualized is inappropriate so like a
drag story I would be inappropriate if
it is actually a drag show well like a
drag the drag costume is like they're
wearing lingerie like they usually do
in in that situation it is inappropriate
so life if but but again there are malt
I've seen multiple stories where it's
like drag show and then you look at it
and it's just a trans woman that is
reading and that's drag people they're
not people in Juggernaut trans I know
what you're I know what you're saying
like no I know what you're saying yeah
but but that is not actually what I'm
telling you is that the story headline
does not marry to the facts what do you
mean by that I'm saying like so drag so
the drag queen story hours a drag queen
comes and reads the kids yeah has not
necessarily been a
I do not think that anything sexualized
should be involved no drag queens in
front of kids
nothing sexualized I just wanna
but why can't you just say I don't
understand
well so it's like you know what drag is
I do so they get on stage they take
clothes off and they're given tips by
the audience yes so stripping is very
similar yes go go dancing and bikini
bars are in states where they don't
allow full nudity right the women will
get up on stage take their costume off
yes and expose on your layers yes drag
is the same none of that is okay what
I'm saying is that what the media has
called drag has not necessarily been
that which is why I'm trying to be very
specific about my language I don't know
any instance that you're talking about
like ever so there's specific events
that are called drag queen Story Hour
and that's what we're talking about yeah
I'm not a fan that is not that would not
be something I would want my kids to be
yeah yeah like I don't think anyone
cares if that's like a trans person like
just reading a kid people do care then
that's what I'm saying that's what I
mean yeah yeah and there are a lot of
people of uh you know there are people
getting mad when white teachers are
talking about stuff that's not in line
with woke values and there's like a
Seattle library created white only
spaces and colored only spaces it was
the weirdest thing ever and deeply
offensive and then I'm sorry people of
color is what they call it but I feel
it's deeply it's the same level of
offense and then Dearborn Michigan did
the same thing so you know you have that
across the board and I think we all just
outright disagree with it
um yeah I think the the problem is the
ideologies of the the disparate culture
War factions are so distinct now that
there is no middle space that people can
occupy yeah and a lot of a lot of times
it is hard I've seen the opposite
problem because I've seen you know media
talking about it but then the actual
photos and videos of it are way worse
than I could even imagine personally
from what I've seen online but my
question was more centered towards the
solution aspect you know when we talk
about a community you wouldn't bring
your children there but would you get
involved or try to prevent this from
from happening or or how can a community
Safeguard against those kind of bad
influences that do provide sexual
content to small children yeah so I you
know I haven't been in that position so
it's hard for me to answer I I worry
like I worry about my children
so you know if other parents think it's
appropriate for their children then they
can make that decision my kids won't
will not be involved in something like
that and that that's the way I look at
it
that's a good point too I think the uh
one of the challenges with this whole
debate over kids and this kind of stuff
is
where people think the government should
be intervening in what uh parents are
showing their kids and so right in the
Bible there are things that are
considered adult
sure but of course you know people who
really just want their kids to read the
Bible I think the issue is just parental
consent if if the parents decide but
there's also got to be limits I suppose
because I think everybody agrees like no
school should be heading Hustler to some
kids and so where where is the line of
those values as a challenge because you
know in the book genderqueer The Right
says it's sexually explicit and
shouldn't be shown but the left says so
what it should be and that's where they
don't agree on the values but to a
conservative you're basically but do you
do you really think that the left when
you say that like it gets it gets very
murky right I don't think that most
Democrats think that you know their
teenage kids should have a book in you
know be handed a book in high school
that uh shows blow jobs or sexual well
these are Great Schools even worse I
don't I don't know you're right like I
don't know anyone on the left that is
like you're you're right this is why
Glenn young can won when the when the
parents because of the zoom School the
parents started learning the schools
we're doing this yeah so the the
challenge is
they lie about it so when you so what do
I see from all of my liberal friends is
they're saying that uh the right is
Banning books and then I'll say
something like well no they're banning
sexually explicit materials and then
they'll say no you're wrong don't care
so you can actually there's plenty of
that I agree with you there's plenty of
that online what do you do when they
keep voting for it like I mean this is
the problem I agree with you and I tell
people all the time the one thing you
should say to your neighbors when you're
talking about politics if you really
want to just say look I don't know about
any of that Trump stuff I just think we
shouldn't be giving children sex change
surgery and they're going to say
overwhelmingly that never happens
and then my response to them is like you
know Jazz Jennings has a show I think on
AMC or some other or I don't know what
channel it's on like yeah they they give
kids sex changes I just I don't I think
it's probably wrong but there are people
who just either won't believe it refuse
to listen to evidence Larry Elder came
on the show and said that
he had a friend who believed the uh The
hoax about Donald Trump I think it was
the very fine people hoax and he said he
pulled up the transcript and says here
just read it and the guy says
no
so what do you do
they just say no they won't do it sure
and that's that's the most common thing
yeah but I mean my experience you know
because I because I uh will sit on
Facebook and I'll see these memes from
all these like occupied Wall Street
people I know
and so I'll just post pictures and then
they'll just delete the comment you know
they'll say like this that or otherwise
happened and then I'll just post a news
story and a picture and they will delete
the comment so no one can see it and I'm
like okay
and the response that I got was that I'm
breaking consensus reality because
that's more important and I was just one
person who told me that but I think that
exemplifies it I think there's people
who just want everyone to fit in yeah I
think it's always good that that you you
know one of the things that I respect
about you is that you push back I don't
always agree with you but I think it's I
think that you structure your thoughts
the right way and that you come at
things
um with the intention of coming to the
truth you know now we might have
different we we might come at it from a
different angle and we might disagree on
some of the the different pieces but I
think that having conversation is
incredibly important yeah and I I think
it it is harder and harder to have
conversation not only because like you
and I are having this conversation but I
know that as a result of you and I
having this conversation I am going to
get a whole bunch of people that like me
and a whole bunch of people that hate me
oh yeah I'm gonna get people that hate
me just because I'm here
right just because I think just because
I came on the show and that is so
different than how I grew up I think
this is a great discussion you know uh
as much as I probably talked too much
but having having pushback on the stuff
we frequently talk about is one of the
most important things we can do so that
I think that's that's fantastic
obviously I think you know the audience
listening probably they listen because
they probably agree with a lot of what I
say sure so they'll probably disagree
with you but a lot of people have been
agreeing with you and some people have
been insulting me and stuff like that I
think that's I think it's I think it's
all good within reason I mean we try to
keep our criticism to to functional but
uh I thought this is a fantastic
conversation let's go to super chats if
you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the share with your
friends be the notification you want to
see from YouTube because they're not
doing it and because uh what do I say go
to timcast.com be a member sure all
right let's read hex mayor says it's so
great to see Nick on creator of the
greatest zombie movie ever range 15.
Nick would love to hear about your car
ride with Alex Soros and Tim Canada
hahaha
what was that all about uh
yeah Alex Soros and Tim Kennedy all
right so this is this is one of the
wildest Things that has happened to me
so Tim and I got back uh we left we left
Afghanistan to uh to UAE and then from
UAE we had to move
um 300 people that were being hosted by
a non-profit and all of this had been
coordinated with state department and uh
the Albanian government and this NGO and
so Tim and I
um are going to bring these 300 people
to Albania so we leave UAE on a Plane
full of uh full of Afghans and you know
we land you know it's like 2 A.M and
like all this press is there there's all
these people and
um you know we're gonna we're supposed
to be meeting everybody at the resort
where all of these Afghans were housed
the next day
and so we get there and it's amazing
Afghan like it the the hap one of the
happiest moments of my life or like you
know some of these kids that were
literally like laying on the tarmac it's
life's had lives had just been in in
Jeopardy and the next time I see them
they are playing tag and they're drawing
pictures and like like literally tears
in my eyes
and then this woman who we had been kind
of you know uh speaking with was like
Hey you know
um Alex wants to meet you guys like you
know he wants to and I have no idea who
we're talking about just like her boss
Alex and so you know this limo pulls up
and and we're we're gonna go get lunch
with Alex and you know so Tim and I get
in the car and there's two bodyguards in
there and there's this dude
um and we're sitting there and you know
we're talking to him he's perfectly nice
and
um
Tim just leans over and he goes
I think I think this is Alex Soros
and I was like bro I I think it is Alex
right how old is he he's like our age
well I say our age I'm I'm older but uh
you know he's how old are you I'm 45. oh
okay yes you are older I'm older yeah
um and uh but yeah he's 30s 40s you know
yeah uh probably like 38 my guess you
want to look it up see how close I am I
say 38 that's my guess well then I'm 36
so our age is yeah so um so then Kennedy
goes he just he he does this look he
looks around looks at both the security
guards and he just goes hey man
uh Nick and I could totally kill you if
we wanted to no he does he does he goes
he's like uh and and he goes like that
guy's the only guy in the car with a gun
and I'm gonna grab him and While I'm
grabbing him Nick's definitely taking
out the other guy and then it's me and
Nick against you and Alex go to his
credit like Stone Face he goes Tim are
you gonna kill me he's like and he Tim's
like no of course not like you know
you're very nice and you're doing a
great thing for these Afghans he's like
good but then his other security guard
this English guy is like I told you we
needed more security
I I take it more as of him giving a
warning to him like you need more
security that's what it was it was it
was all in good nobody actually like he
wasn't threatening anymore wow that's a
crazy story but it was it was like we
got in this vehicle and we just we had
no idea
man we had no way and it was like
like you know that's correct he's 36.
and uh I was in the ballpark he used to
come on the show be great to talk to him
hey I'll tell you what like you know he
was great I'll just say he was great and
he was they very generous to the Afghans
I'll say that yeah I always think it's
important to give people credit when
they do things that are good 100 you
know positive outcome even if like you
know I'll give AOC credit when she
called out the police on January 6 for
opening the doors and all that stuff I'm
like she's right let's get an
investigation I want to know what
happened with that because that means
there may be some innocent people in
jail I mean some people who should be
aren't
all right we got Catherine Gillen says
in the UK the TCS have changed our bank
have changed our bank accounts quote if
there is an unstable economy that
affects the banking markets we will
limit your funds and if you have too
much money in your account we will
charge you
wow someone look that up and see if
they're reporting on that yeah that's
all you yeah I'd love to see that what's
it uh Bank bank limits UK war or
something I don't know because the pound
was collapsing this seems you know that
makes sense yeah man
Sam says my brother was in Afghanistan
during the surrender at Bagram he said
it was like they woke up that morning
and made the decision totally unplanned
yeah
that's crazy is that sound like that
that's consistent with everything I've
heard is it was a huge surprise they
didn't even tell the Afghans that they
were leaving they just left in the
middle of the night and then they looted
the the base it's crazy
trash Banner says Nick love your few
cartoons especially the gun control one
oh yeah my drill sergeant showed my
platoon in basic down at Fort Benning
hope it's hope is not a plan
uh so a while ago I had a animated
cartoon called the Damn Few when I was
uh when I was still running when I was
still running Ranger up uh and uh it's
like uh it started off like two minute
videos and then by the end we were doing
full like 30 minute episodic animations
so that was a lot of fun right on
Catherine Gillen adds more as London has
a big hand in the world's financial
markets with Libor this is really
bothering me as it looks like they might
try to freeze our bank accounts they
have already done this in Greece before
everyone check your bank's terms and
conditions oh that's what you're saying
TC's
um you know Catherine I really do
appreciate the British pounds you've
sent it's just you know the values drop
so much
I I I I I actually was in Greece when
they prevented people from taking money
out of out of their own accounts and
there was just massive riots I saw so
much violence in the streets there and
it and it happens a lot it happens in so
many different places around the world
um I was there on the ground reporting
in Zimbabwe as well it happened recently
in China they just sent tanks on the
streets there because people can't get
their money out of their Bank bank
accounts in Lebanon people are literally
going to the banks with guns holding the
the gun so she had a fake gun yeah yeah
because they they don't want the bank's
money they want their own money and the
banks are saying we're not going to give
it to you there there was a famous guy
who had to pay for his father's surgery
couldn't pay for it literally got a gun
became a national case and those cases
are becoming more common all over the
world this is why you know the first
thing I did when um you know after the
end of the year comes in profits roll in
is I took 250 000 and lined the inside
of a banana stand that I have
like there's always money in the bananas
yeah just in case because you know
there's always I'll tell you what the
more you I mean you know this you've
traveled overseas a lot like when when I
travel overseas like I travel with a lot
of cash because you just
like you don't know like you know in
like Ukraine the right amount too much
is bad you can't go over two thousand
dollars right or ten thousand ten ten
thousand I heard they limited that
basically ten thousand without paying
taxes taxes on it because then I think
you're doing some kind of business but
like in Ukraine you know
um it's hard to get cash very hard to
get cash yeah yeah people are using
Bitcoin leave no so we you know we
travel with a bunch of American Cash
every time wow that were that were over
there yeah I remember when I was in uh
when I was covering news in Kiev and uh
we had a bunch of British pounds and
dollars and we were paying people with
British pounds and dollars and they were
just like shocked because the exchange
rate's nuts like people there get the
equivalent of a couple hundred bucks a
month for their salaries yep and then
here we come in these like you know
westerners covering news it was back in
2014. yeah and we were just like to us
it was normal to be like oh here grab
some food hand them 20 bucks and they go
oh I don't need that much no thank you
and we're like yeah okay like you know
hey that's cool man I remember when
Landing in India during their Currency
Reset utter chaos all the money was just
devalued right away
I was in I was in the the former Soviet
Union right after the collapse of
Communism uh as well yeah is as part of
the uh the Eisenhower program so I was
like 16 17 and uh spent a few months in
in Russia and at the time
um
you know only a few years prior it was
close to one to one and uh it was like a
thousand rubles to the dollar and I was
like a rich high school kid I was like
this is amazing you know I came back
with all kinds of like art and stuff
that I never would have been able to
afford Tetris yeah all right Lou sassle
says Nick thank you for everything
you've done recently watched send me and
it was amazing slash heartbreaking truly
opens your eyes to what happened screw
that kernel now Excuse me while I go
watch range 15. Jean Van Den Ham could
have saved Afghanistan he could have he
could have done so send me is the
documentary send me is the documentary
so when I uh when I went over there when
we all went over there I I threw a Canon
C70 in my backpack and uh bless you and
you know
um filmed you know uh what was going on
and then you know when we got back to
UAE did some interviews and then spent
you know over the last year year I've
interviewed everybody again that was
there and we put together a documentary
that kind of told the real story of how
bad it was because the U.S media you
know kind of made it seem like you know
oh the Taliban are working with
Americans and everything's fine you know
or meanwhile like on the ground you know
people are the Taliban are you know
shooting people anytime any anything got
people got riled up they would just you
know fire an AK into the crowd
um you know one of my friends you know
was uh trying to get this woman out you
know she wasn't this wasn't part of our
group part of a different group
um and uh they they murdered her right
on the hood of the car there was nothing
they could do about it
um you know just like I mean really
horrible stuff was happening and you
know nobody nobody Stateside was really
telling that story it was just like oh
this is a peaceful you know and they
they were they were not attacking
Americans but they were certainly
attacking after scans and so we just
tried to tell the honest story of of
kind of what happened and what it was
like and we thought it was important
that the American people see it
um where can they find it it's on Amazon
Prime and um
you know any funds that come into it get
donated to the organization that uh you
know Tim Kennedy Chad robichau Sarah
verardo and I founded called save our
allies that was that all proceeds or
just profits no literally all of it so
there's there's no like cost it's just
like if someone spends 20 bucks in the
video that 20 bucks goes right to the
charity yes well I mean like whatever
Amazon takes but but all revenue goes
like we set up an LLC all revenue goes
to that LLC and then you know
essentially like uh I mean I'm sure
we'll have to pay like an accountant but
other than that like we are not taking
anything from it not even to like recoup
costs or anything why did you not make a
charity why an LLC
um so just any time that you make uh
like a movie you want it to be its own
LLC just like there's
you know this yeah like you know like
they want us every song to be its own
company that's just crazy potential
lawsuits potential problems you know
like in when you're when it's a when
it's an NGO there's there's so many more
rules about a 40 a 501c3 the things you
have to do so this way it's just like
hey like whatever money comes into that
thing we just cut a check over oh two
and out to a non-profit two
specifically to save our allies which is
you know in the wake of Afghanistan
um you know a good chunk of the people
that were part of that that evacuation
stood up this 501c3 you know to continue
doing that work and so you know and that
work has gotten more and more
frustrating because it's harder and
harder to move Afghans
um but you know so we're still helping
Afghans and then we also have a another
uh part of the organization that is
doing work in Ukraine all right Steve
Cohen says saw Luke in that HBO
documentary the anarchist felt like they
may try to drag you guys soon with that
why was it bad depiction there's nothing
really to drag
did they show you like doing drugs no no
Ayahuasca no no it looks like seeing
space demons no no no no no no it was an
interesting uh a series to say the least
but uh is it a series yeah yeah the
depiction wasn't uh you know as as
honest as I thought it should be but all
right 11 Bravo nrd says for Nick with
inflation going on does my Ranger up
five-year challenge coin only get me an
eight ounce beer instead of the full
12-ounce beer Baker Boys 1 through 15.
third idea I will buy the full 12 ounce
beer don't worry about it oh man taking
a loss doing the right thing foreign
all right
powder pz says if we were in a sane
World Biden would have been forced to
resign by now but unfortunately we live
in clown world and that just means
Kamala Harris be president right
is that it I guess
well all right Grayson Hendricks says
you obviously read a lot on history and
you also say it's written by the Victor
given that how do you determine which
books on history to trust been a member
for about a year love the show uh don't
know you don't history is written by The
Victors you can try and find depictions
from other people so I'm really
interested in you know I mentioned this
couple times I went to Stonewall
Jackson's headquarters for when he was
running defense for the Shenandoah
Valley and there's a book there's a book
you wrote and I'm like I'd like to read
it but that's how you do it you know
like that dude certainly wrote his
perspective on the Civil War you can
read his perspective I mean yo Hitler
wrote a book like you can read it if you
want to you know so but it is true
there's a lot on History that's fake and
when you look at the media operates
today you know that it's probably Faker
than you thought
what do you do
I wonder if there's that message that
smallpox wiped out the Native American
population 90 of it I'm starting to even
question that that's what we were told
for all I know they went in there with
weapons and killed them all and they
were like no disease did it it wasn't us
Zach michiel says someone tell Nick to
bring back BNN or apologize to the
plants for wasting the oxygen they
worked so hard to make JK probably
what is what was BNN so uh for a few
years we had this show called the bad
news network and uh basically it was
like kind of a comedic look at the news
but we covered serious topics like we
went in depth on every topic but we did
it in a way that was uh manageable so
the show was usually 20 to 30 minutes
you know we did it once a week and it
was like a recap of the big stuff that
happened that week
um but it was uh it's it's technically
owned by Ranger up and so when I sold
the controlling share of that like you
know I stopped doing it we're in the
process of coming up with a different
show so there will be something new soon
right on free men Die free says blueanon
has embraced all the pillars of
totalitarianism Civil War will be the
end result because it is incompatible to
our libertarian foundations
or you know I think one possibility
that would potentially avoid war is if
we start building up culture this guy um
Vivek ramaswamy is that his name
investor goes to Disney says stop
getting woke if these companies actually
start rejecting this then you'll see a
lot of these weirdo cold people break
out and be like oh I I never supported
that stuff or oh don't look at me and
that will kind of simmer things down but
that's a that's a hopefully you know
don't know for sure what exactly would
happen but
I don't know man it seems like things
have been been getting crazy brewmaster
monk says forget Yuri bezmanov watch the
Kate Griggs interview from 1998 spouse
to a chief of staff colonel in the
Marines spilling the beans on
epstein-esque blackmail in the highest
levels of the military you ever hear
that Luke
um what's the name again K Griggs
interview
I happen to look into this
all right take a look into it uh as Luke
is doing that I will be looking at some
of these super chats
I would say there are legit reasons to
see the left and the establishment as
enemies look at what they are doing to
kids realize that these things aren't
happening to an abstract group of kids
but rather to your kids I fight to
protect my kids lives
yeah
well
these are tough times I've seen this
video like 20 years ago yeah what is it
um I have to refresh my memory it was a
very long time ago I have it pulled up
on YouTube right now I'm gonna re-watch
it but it's two hours long oh wow Jeremy
B says damn Tim is getting us drunk
tonight that's right everybody you know
I think we said Civil War enough now to
wear a woof
Jon Jones says Tim I'm a Tim cast member
and I listen to your shows as a podcast
you really need to have a members link
that is ad free as in the last few
months you have gone overboard with
in-show adverts other podcasts offer ad
free links we have not changed our ad
structures at all at any point nothing
has changed so if more ads are appearing
it might be because YouTube
automatically puts them in or something
but I don't know it also depends on
where you're watching too because I
think we do what like seven ads in the
whole uh podcast
yeah seven or eight seven yep it's
always seven but like seven out of two
hours right you know so over two hours
they're spaced on like every 20 minutes
not bad yeah no I think it's actually
like way less than most people do but it
could be that you know whatever system
you're listening on or on the back end
for these platforms they could be they
could be doubling up or something I
don't know yeah oh yeah you know what I
bet they do double them up the daily
wire definitely does more and then if
you don't like what your platform's
doing try a different platform we are
working on a mobile app and once we have
that mobile app we will have the ad-free
versions and all of that stuff or we're
trying to
um it's it's remarkable with the way the
economy is right now it's remarkable how
hard it is to get anything done we were
supposed to have construction started a
year ago on freedomastan and it started
I think like three months ago and it was
supposed to take two weeks and it
started three months ago so that's where
we're at
let's grab some more Super chats
Mount Jeeves says is that mountain Jews
some people don't seem to realize not
acting for the sake of saving your
possessions or money or family doesn't
really make any sense they're killing
your kids right now they're taking
everything away with inflation I would
say figuratively killing your kids or
their their there's a major detriment
happening to the future of this country
in that your kids will have
substantially less than you did I
wouldn't be surprised if your
grandchildren don't have air
conditioning or refrigerators and I
really do mean that because humans got
by without them and they
you will owe nothing and you will be
happy
there you go man
let's grab some more Super chats try and
find something good there was one I
wanted to read but I can't seem to find
it
all right the snack lady Jackie says I
live in North Carolina none of the rest
of our state except Asheville is like
Chapel Hill Nick has no idea what kids
are being taught and most of North
Carolina sees the virtue signaling of
Chapel Hill uh virtual signaling of
Chapel Hill ch
okay yeah all right
I don't know what to say to that
all right
what do we got here
pinochet's helicopter tours interesting
name it says as a retired army 11b
myself to pretend the government has a
monopoly on force and is always in the
right seems contrary to the oath I took
and history
but I do think there's a lot of people
who are in the armed forces
who will just follow orders
yeah yeah I've asked people that's what
history dictates but but I've asked
people this question so
I I've spent some time on some military
bases at a family and the answer that I
said if you were ordered to shoot you
know like some guy in a street corner
American says when you do it they're
like probably
like the the assumption that people are
making when you you think the soldier
would say no is that the person is
Innocent but the Assumption the soldier
is making is I trust my chain of command
and my commanding officer they're not
telling me to randomly kill an innocent
person we're trying to you know if they
say stop that person take them out it
could be a person with a weapon a bomb a
murderer yeah I think that I think
that's probably true for an individual
moment but like a sustained operation
like if you told a platoon like you know
I'm thinking back to when I was a
platoon leader if I told my platoon hey
we're gonna go
uh you know storm Greenville and start
killing people like I am very sure they
would not listen to me right I am very I
mean Vietnam was crazy I'm very sure of
that so you know I I think give people
give the military some credit I I do not
think that in general terms the military
wants to take any action against
against the country unless it is like a
true crisis what was the University that
had the National Guard shoot up the
chicken State what about Kent State
yeah that's conflicting history on that
yeah yeah so I mean you know Kent State
you had National Guard members that are
that you know had at the time the
National Guard then was not the National
Guard now where there was like real
training that hadn't been in you know
any kind of aggressive situation before
and they had people throwing rocks at
them and it was an agre you know they
you think that can't happen now though
of course anything can happen like I
mean people are we're all we're fancy
monkeys right so like you know I mean
you know if
you know if you're not trained and
you're afraid you're going to make bad
decisions and so like it you know
everything that you talk Tim Kennedy
always talks about training you know
like if you are used to
being in crisis if you're used to you
know yeah but the military chain of
command is a lot smarter I mean they
have people literally on their computers
dropping bombs on weddings on American
teenagers and American soldiers are
doing it without you know without any
problems
it happened you're talking about it
drown strike you're talking about
overseas drone strikes yeah yeah I mean
so so that's a whole other moral debate
that we can get over I'm talking about
in the United States you know asking
like an infantry platoon to go like
shoot up a town like it's not gonna
happen like what if they say we got a
bunch of Maga extremists they're far
right and they've been plotting an
attack I think if somebody's plotting an
attack that's different right how is the
soldier gonna know that they are yeah
their chain of command will say it's
happening and they'll say we'll stop
that and it could be some dude playing
GTA in his living room
I I you know as as a former military
officer I have a lot more confidence uh
you know not only in the officer Corps
but explicitly in the non-commissioned
officer Corps but this is no disrespect
to to the soldiers it's a it's a
statement of the the impossibilities if
you have a Commanding Officer says look
we've got a group of guys who've been
plotting some kind of terror attack on a
bridge we're gonna go stop them then
they shout they show up in their
vehicles and sure enough here's the
group as described their Maga Hassan
armed they're not going to be like
I don't trust myself his armed group you
know that's true and these guys could be
like doing a Veterans Memorial and and
have no idea but some power some person
wants to get rid of it that's why I mean
the chain of commands not gonna say hey
kill your neighbor kill your brother
they're far more sophisticated when they
have an operation that they need to
carry out look at uh the collateral one
last point the collateral murder video
that was released by Wikileaks they were
celebrating the murder of Reuters
journalists but I've got to come back
after you're done absolutely because
absolutely yeah there is no
the
if if you if you if you served in the
military you realize how hard it would
be to do some of these things that
you're that you're describing like where
where you're gonna get Waco all of these
guys well that's a different situation
right where you're going to get all of
these guys to be in on some kind of a
conspiracy they won't be in on it so I
was a uh
there was when remember that uh failed
coup attempt in Turkey yep I'm sure the
details have changed by now so fact fact
check that the the change details but
what was being reported at the time a
bunch of soldiers
drove onto the Bosphorus Bridge which
controls entry into the Black Sea
then all of a sudden we started seeing
shooting from helicopters and the media
reported that it was a coup attempt
those soldiers on the bridge it was
reported had no idea what was going on
but civilians came grabbed them and beat
them and dragged them through the
streets I think many of them were killed
what apparently happened and this was a
report at the time so it may not be true
they may have updated the story but what
I was told was
and not what I saw but was actually on
Twitter and going through the news was
that a bunch of uh privates low-ranking
guys were told we need to do a security
exercise on this bridge because there's
a risk of a terror attack and they went
sounds good to us and then they got a
bunch of soldiers on the bridge
and then the media came out and said
they're staging a coup look they're
doing it now got it so everyone ran up
and started attacking them so if if they
came down and said we got another
Whitmer style plot and the the local law
enforcement is unable to handle it
they're calling it The National Guard
their Insurrection act here's a picture
of the guys they need to be detained by
any means necessary because they could
have bombs on them these guys aren't
going to be like
I don't believe you they're going to be
like oh no no of course not they're
going to be a life of course and I trust
the Intel yeah but but you could have a
group of guys who are just basically
like marching around demanding a
petition but they're there armed legally
so these guys roll up and they see a
bunch of dudes and they jump out and
they're like don't move put your weapons
down and then these guys are like what's
happening they get rounded up brought to
a camp
those those privates those uh lower
ranking guys aren't in on anything
they're doing what they believe to be
true and correct because they trust
their chain of command but the chain of
command could be corrupt sure it might
not even be their immediate Co it could
go up way high to like some lunatic like
Millie or something just like in Waco
they said oh they're shooting at us we
gotta shoot him back sorry and now
children are burning I know I'm gonna
make more enemies but I have to I have
to stick up for Millie I mean like I'll
tell you right now I don't know that
anybody other than than uh Senator
Tillis leaned forward more uh to help
with the extraction of the folks in
Afghanistan
um you know it's it's important I can
respect it's important to remember that
you know one Millie is not the president
he serves at the uh the benefit of the
president and two he is not a commander
you know he he is in a purely advisory
role
um
you know so affected by the cat no no
it's no problem
you know I know for a fact that he was
not
you know he he did not support the
decisions that that were made around the
extraction of Afghanistan and so like
Hey listen if you want to criticize them
for other things I mean like you know
there's certainly you know as with all
people there's good and bad but I will
tell you that like he gets a lot of heat
but he was one of the only people
fighting for the Afghan people during
the extraction we'll grab one right here
okay uh how do I pronounce this oh Kami
horo says Nick is 100 correct about
localizing your efforts yes furthermore
people like this tend to be more
involved in their local elections school
boards Etc efforts should be placed
locally and over time it will grow I I
definitely agree vote locally folks on
your schools focus on your local your
neighbors meet your neighbors talk to
your neighbors organize with your
neighbors and really if everybody at the
Grassroots work towards their Community
then we'd have one big beautiful
Community up top
all right if you haven't already which
kindly smash that like button subscribe
to this channel share the share with
your friends smash that like button I
said that I go to timcast.com become a
member check out all of our member
content check out the cast Castle Vlog
because we've been slowly improving it
doing more episodes more guest cameos
apparently this past episode people are
saying is their favorite because we had
um a bunch of crazy cameos like Viva
Fray Viva fry and he's great other
people did cameos to appear in the cast
Castle Vlog so we want to improve the
quality that's what we're working on
we're getting better at it every week
and we're gonna have a new episode every
Tuesday at 7 p.m you can follow the show
at timcastirl you can follow me at
timcast Nick do you want to shout
anything out
yeah just you know check out send me on
Amazon Prime
um support save our allies.org
tremendous organization that uh you know
obviously I'm biased I you know I was
one of the founders but
um you know we've helped 17 000 plus
Afghans thus far and uh we're doing
incredible work in Ukraine in uh you
know medical evacuation Logistics
um you know helping a lot of people that
are suffering and uh yeah that's it
sweet thanks for coming on my website is
lukeansensor.com I have my own members
area hundreds of videos from 2012 master
classes Forum exclusive merchandise you
name it all on Luke uncensored.com thank
you so much for coming on we didn't
agree with some stuff but that's okay
thank you for at least having a
conversation yeah and I think the
conversation is definitely worth having
in different perspective and viewpoints
are always welcome thank you for uh
expressing those and thanks for having
me and being being yourself and in uh is
there getting taxoplasmosis
is he in the shock we get a wide shot of
this fine feline I can't widen that one
sorry you can only see him a little bit
he's drinking Ian's water for some
reason he only will drink Ian's powers
of our water combined
what's up everybody uh take care of
yourself tonight make something cool
this weekend yeah this is great advice
thank you guys all very much for tuning
in for our conversation with Nick it's
Friday I hope you all are chilling you
guys can follow me on Twitter and
minds.com at Sour Patch Lids as well as
sourpatch lids.me we're gonna go hang
out chill have a good time and I hope
you all enjoy your weekend thanks for
hanging out we'll have Clips up
throughout the weekend on this channel
and then we'll see you all once again on
Monday bye guys